And it would go four,
three,
two,
one.
And we're alive.
You fucking handsome bastard.
Look at you.
Oh Shit.
What's going on man?
What's going on?
Um,
every,
well,
I've done this once before and
I've watched you throughout
the years and when I
come in here,
I get a little,
um,
nervous.
Why?
You're a guy who knows a lot about
everything and I don't know a lot of,
I don't know a lot about everything.
I know enough to make it seem like
I know a lot about everything.
Whatever you're doing,
it's,
you know more than I do.
Right?
Like,
like we were on your treadmill out
there.
Right?
And you go,
it's 13% that,
what did you say?
13% more difficult than regular running.
Okay.
I forgot the fact.
What you just said from
the time we walk in,
I lost it.
So I don't,
I don't have the retention
that I wish I had.
So you some Alpha brain it,
I need something.
Do we have any here?
Is that what I'm missing in my,
that and my Diet Alpha?
Uh,
what's interesting though is that
people will come up to me with shit that
happened just a few years ago.
And I'm like,
I don't remember that at all.
Like I think you have a certain
amount of room in your brain.
And a,
my brain is always deleting stuff that
it doesn't think it needs anymore.
And then shoving in new things.
Like sometimes someone will
tell me about something,
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
And they're like,
you don't remember there was the guy
with no arms who drove us around.
I went,
what?
And then I have to go.
Oh yeah.
It's like I find the
folder in my head and like,
oh,
there it is.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then we went to the pool hall and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And then I'll remember.
Gotcha.
But if,
yeah,
it's just for whatever reason this,
uh,
I can only,
I only keep things that I'm interested in.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
I just wish I could retain a lot of
the things I either see or hear to then
recall it in a conversation.
You can,
but you got to write things down and
you got to like want to recall things.
Yeah,
that's a problem.
I don't do a lot of writing as far as
like a notepad or anything to just take
notes.
When you write your act,
you write it in your head or do you
write it on paper or it's all audio?
Just audio.
I'll go to the comedy store.
I record it and I listened to it
on the way home and then I'll go,
oh,
maybe I'll do this next time.
Maybe I'll do that.
I'll take that out and this out.
And then,
uh,
so there's no writing.
My Act is more recalling stories
than sitting in a room going on.
I think this is funny.
So that's kind of how I work.
But uh,
yeah,
the reason I say that to
start off is just like I,
I see you go down a lot of different
paths on the podcast and I often the gold
man,
if I was sitting in that chair,
could I add to the conversation?
And a lot of times it's,
no,
I can't kid just because
for whatever the reason I,
uh,
I just feel like I need
to be a little bit more,
um,
well-read.
How often you read?
Uh,
like I read the Goggins
Book and that fucking book.
Yeah.
And that dude had,
huh,
it's sad life.
But then on the flip side,
inspiring to,
you know,
a guy like myself were,
I'm running,
I'm running say,
or I'm working out and I,
I thought of this guy,
go,
you know what,
let's,
let's put another mile into this.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
I'm just now starting to get into a
little bit more books than I have in the
past because in the past,
to be honest with you,
I haven't really,
I haven't really read much.
I try to read a one new thing a week.
And the way I try to do it is,
uh,
I have,
I use a lot of audio books,
but I also read books.
So I go back and forth in between them
in between reading and audio books.
But I find for whatever reason I retained
more with audio books than I do with
reading.
I,
maybe it's my add or something like that.
Cause when I'm reading I kind
of have to back up sometimes.
Like I'll go through a whole paragraph
or I'm thinking about some other shit
while I'm reading and then I've got to go,
okay asshole backup,
reread that,
go over it again.
You know,
that's what I find.
I,
I my mind wanders like you're saying the
audio book definitely is better option
Austin up comedians have
scatter brains at least in some,
in some way.
All of us are a little fucked up.
I think we have to be,
I think,
I think that the mind works in a
weird way in a comedians had a,
I think it has to be a
little bit fragmented and uh,
thinking a lot of different things
at once in order to operate.
Uh,
I mean you're doing it on stage.
I think,
you know,
you're doing,
you're doing your comedy and
I'm self evaluating going,
is this working right now?
Should I go off into another bitch?
And I talk about my family.
I see they're liking family stuff.
So I think,
yeah,
that's what we're doing a,
when we're performing and then sometimes
I think that bleeds to everyday life.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
When you're doing a bit,
are you thinking about what you're like,
are you like,
do you have a bid on deck?
Like while you were in
the middle of the bit,
do you let go from there?
I'm going to talk about the gym or the,
you know,
this or that.
Uh,
it's funny.
and I don't know if you go through this.
Do you ever go through,
well,
first of all,
when you're doing comedy,
do you have a beginning,
middle and end and you know where you're
going throughout that whole set or do
you in the moment going,
you know what,
I'm going to do the bet amount that,
that,
uh,
or is it set?
It's both.
It depends when,
like right now,
uh,
I don't have a lot of material because,
my Netflix special came out in October,
so November,
December,
January,
I've basically three
months worth of new shit,
which is about 40 minutes
of all told material.
And then I have 20 other
minutes that are in the,
they're in like the baking stage.
Like I'm not ready to take
them out of the oven there.
I fuck around with them.
I'll shove them in the
middle a bit some sometimes,
but they're not,
they're not 100% legit.
They need to be fleshed out.
But one of those became
like one of my best bits.
Now it's weird how that works.
Like sometimes you'll just find this one
part of it that makes it work and boom,
all of a sudden the bits turbocharged.
Um,
so because of that,
I usually,
I decide that day usually
what I'm going to open with.
And then,
um,
I leave the middle part up
to my imagination and then
I'll decide what I'm going
to close with.
But when I'm ready to
do a Netflix special,
I basically have it all mapped out.
I basically have a starting
point and I have an end point.
Yeah.
But even like when I'm filming,
I still fuck around and ad Lib cause
I don't think because every show I do,
I don't,
I don't have like,
I'm going to say it verbatim this way
every time I always fuck around because I
always feel like I could find a new
way that's better if I just stay loose.
And so even when I'm filming,
I do it that way because I feel I
want this to be like a real show.
If it's a real show and
I always film for shows,
so I'm like,
if it's a real show,
I'll fuck around.
And I've,
I've been filming before,
I fuck around and I go down a dark
road and there's no one there.
I'm like,
all right,
turn around.
Thank God for that.
Yeah.
I think,
I think that's the way to do it though,
to be kind of in the moment and go with
how you're feeling when you're filming
something just because that's
the way you would be anyway.
But sometimes I've,
I've,
I've learned in the past
when I'm filming something,
I feel like,
man,
I'd like to get everything that I want
out on this special and I don't want to
forget anything because there'd be
nights where I'm performing and I,
I,
I forgot a bit.
I'm like,
I'll be searching in my head
for the bit and I'm like,
I know there's another
something that goes along this,
but then I just jump off it and go into,
uh,
another routine.
So for me,
I dunno,
I like to keep it different every night,
just try and play around.
And,
uh,
it's weird now that a Netflix special,
I just,
uh,
one came out and I don't
really subscribe to.
Um,
if,
if I have a Netflix special out
and you come to a live show,
you're going to see some of those bits
that I did in the Netflix special.
I don't like retire the,
the act.
I know some guys go,
okay,
it's out there.
I'm not doing this on my live show myself.
I still like to do some of that
material cause I enjoy doing it.
And,
uh,
I also have some new stuff,
so I kind of,
and I don't know how long that lasts.
I don't know.
Like,
I,
I know some,
some people were like,
oh,
I saw that on the Netflix.
Why am I going to pay to see it
live if I could see it at home?
But there's something about going out I
believe to a live show and seeing a live
performance.
There's different nuances that you
might see in a bit or an add on.
Like sometimes I add onto the joke that
my jokes are sometimes never finished,
so we keep adding on.
So,
um,
that's the way I've kind of
worked at my entire career.
Yeah.
Um,
Gaffigan does it that way.
uh,
Brian Regan does it that way where guys
will call out bits like the w like if
you go to see gafcon and
he doesn't do hot pockets,
you're going to get fucking Matt.
That's this.
A lot of people like that
I retire my material,
but,
uh,
I have brought stuff out before.
If people ask,
like,
someone asked me to bring up,
uh,
explaining Kim Kardashians to
the aliens the other night.
And I was amazed that I could remember it,
but I remembered it a,
but for the most part,
I retire shit because
I feel like in my mind,
if I don't retire things I'm not going
to work on new things as much in the new
limit myself.
And then I always feel like my newest
bits are better than my older bits because
even though I've been
doing standup for 30 years,
I still think I get better at it.
I think it's a constant state of self
evaluation and self analysis and going
over the material and then realize,
you know,
you have enough good sets
and bad sets and great sets.
You have enough the kind of recognize the
characteristics of each one where they
go wrong,
and then you get better at having
less bad sets and even less good sets,
a more great sets.
And,
you know,
and I think that for me,
one big part of that
is constantly writing.
I write,
write,
I sit down at a,
right,
right.
And,
uh,
I write,
I have one hour every night after shows.
That's one big one.
I went during the day,
but the big one for me seems to be at
night when I come home from the store and
I'm jazzed up.
And also it's great too
because everyone's asleep.
It's just me and the dog
and I just fucking sit at
that desk and I'll just work
until my eyes start blinking and
I start getting really tired.
And some of my best shit ever come up
with is that way after shows cause I'm
all,
I'm juiced up and then also have a
process of listening to the show.
I'm in the car.
Cause you know,
that's one of the coolest things about um,
Bluetooth audio that you get your phone,
you recorded on your phone and then in
the car home you can listen and you can
go,
oh I fucked that up.
Or Oh I should have done it this way.
Or maybe if I do that or you have an idea,
like I'll pause it.
Oh I got another idea and then I'll make
a new voice note and then I'll go home.
And I'll listen to it again.
I'll listen to my set again and I'll
pause it and start working on stuff.
And that's how I've been able to
expand all these bits pretty quickly.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
I,
uh,
high find my best bits come out
of just living my life and um,
you know,
I have a daughter and we went to the
zoo and the nuances at the zoo that I
picked up on and I just go on either Tom,
I'll call my mother and I'll tell her a
story and that's Kinda my barometer of
whether or not this thing is going to
work on stage and then I'll go to the
comedy store and kind
of flush it out there.
But uh,
yeah,
I mean,
I just never been the guy who writes.
Um,
I just,
I dunno.
Well you don't have to.
No,
I,
yeah,
it works for you.
There's a lot of guys
don't do it that way.
Bill Bird doesn't do it that way.
He's one of the best ever.
Yeah.
A lot of guys who just don't,
right.
Um,
for me,
I feel like it's all about how much
time and energy I put on things.
And if I put more time and energy,
you know,
just working on my act
because I'm writing,
then it's going to be better.
That's just how I look at it.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
everybody's got their own process and
I'm fascinated to hear like guys like
yourself,
if Seinfeld's and other guy that a,
every word is planned out
and you could hear it with him too.
You really hear it.
His Act is like a scalpel,
you know,
it was just,
he's slicing the perfect slice and he's,
he's,
he knows exactly how does that,
he's got perfect timing.
He's got his use of words is,
you know,
whether or not you,
any comic can appreciate that any comic
can appreciate the way he does that.
You know,
there's a lot of guys who are
like that who just have that.
Did you ever watch Jenny at all?
I have and uh,
you know,
his timing I think was,
I think timing in comedy is something,
a bit of a lost art.
I don't think a lot of comedians are
really taking to timing like they have in
the past and I don't know if there
are scared of the silence because,
because a lot of timing is silent and a
lot of guys and women tend to not relish
in those moments of silence
where sometimes it's,
it's comedy gold.
A lot of people run through the material
and for me as an audience member,
I like someone who kind of gives
you as an audience member a little,
a little beat or maybe maybe some time
to kind of marinate in the joke a little
bit opposed to kind of
blowing through the material.
Don't you feel that like when you're
in a large audience that's even more
critical because you have like there's
thousands of people and it seems like a
big pause like in between punchlines
or you give a person a chance,
give this whole group of people a chance
to think about how ridiculous what you
just said was,
yeah,
it enhances it.
Oh absolutely.
I mean,
especially like you said
in a large audience,
which is even more fearful for a comedian
to let the joke breathe has God knows,
you know,
if you got a thousand people
and then you got 20,000 people,
I mean know 19 more thousand people
could yell or scream or say something.
So anything can go wrong.
Yeah.
But man to stop and just let that
joke breathe a little bit and just,
and then maybe have it perculate there's
times where I'm on stage in and out
goal a little bit longer than I thought
I was going to go without talking,
but maybe give it like a
facial expression or whatnot,
just to see if I could eat out
another crescendo of laughter and um,
those are the moments I really relish
in because sometimes the silence is even
better than saying anything.
Yeah.
And you also realize that you're
not like rushing anything.
You got Ahold of it.
Yeah.
At least for my self,
my act is more like a,
um,
it needs to,
it needs to kind of sit.
I don't really do well on like
five minute talk shows doing like,
you know,
doing a four and a half
minutes set on Fallon.
I need to like go out there.
I did,
it takes me two minutes to t to get warm.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
uh,
I to get into a joke right
away and it had to me,
I just,
I need time.
I need,
I need to let it breathe.
Yeah,
no,
I feel the same way.
I,
I've always felt those late night
talk show sets are so strange.
Not only that,
but you're basically opening for yourself.
I mean,
cause there's no one has done
standup yet except a monologue.
Just kind of stand up a kind of knob
because it's all like what's happening
today and everybody knows
that it's been written.
It's,
it's weird.
Yeah.
And then you go out and do a standup set
and oftentimes you see guys go out and
they'll do a stand up set and
they don't even have a microphone.
You know,
they're doing a standup
set and they don't know
fuck to do with their hands.
You know,
it's hard.
The first time I did a standup set on,
uh,
on TV.
I said,
I need the microphone.
Yeah.
I can't go out there.
I've been doing comedy for what,
12 years it had been,
and then I got like a Leno.
I need a physical microphone.
I'm used to this.
I don't,
I'm not going to go out
there all of a sudden now.
And uh,
like you said,
what am I going to with my hands?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
every time I do a late night
said I need a microphone.
How well do you still do those?
Um,
no,
not any more.
I,
I like to do,
it's a comedy on the couch now.
You know,
it's,
it's like you go on Fallon or what have
you and it's all premeditated burrs.
The master at that,
the master,
he's the best at sitting down there and
saying something fucked up and they just
like,
you know,
he's good.
He's just got a great way
of handling the couch.
Yeah.
He makes it sound like just two guys
talking and then there's cameras filming
it.
Yeah.
Sometimes it could look like,
oh,
okay.
You ask the question.
I give the answer,
but for whatever the reason,
it's so natural for him.
It's like this guy looks
like he's talking in a,
at a diner.
Exactly.
Yeah.
No,
he's,
uh,
he's mastered the art
of not giving a fuck.
He's very comfortable.
And if you,
you know,
like,
but that's
who we is all day.
You know,
he just ramps it up a couple of
extra clicks when he goes on stage.
That's when you're hanging out with them.
That's bird.
Yeah.
It's not a far departure from now,
from what we're seeing.
Scott,
one thing down to that guy does
not fuck with social media.
He's not doing nothing.
Oh,
he's not even on it.
I mean,
he,
he like Kinda,
I guess he posts stuff.
Well,
you know,
I follow them on Instagram and every
once in a while I'll see something.
Yeah.
Um,
which,
you know,
for me,
I've kind of weaned off the
social media a little bit.
Um,
I know a lot of guys live on it
and they take you into their lives.
And here's,
you know,
here I follow Bert Kreischer.
So every,
I'm wondering if the people
around Bert Kreischer are,
are going to him.
All right,
Burt,
you want to lose the phone?
You know,
like we're all,
we're having dinner here.
Oh yeah.
Um,
because man,
he really gives you a bird's eye
view into not only his family life,
but he's on a ski lift and he's got the,
you know,
skis and this and that.
So,
which I appreciate.
It's just for me.
I don't know.
Is there some little sense of privacy?
Uh,
every once in a while births defense.
What Bert did was he had a legit TV gig.
He was doing birth the conqueror
and what was the other one?
The other one where he's
traveling around chip flip,
chip flip.
And uh,
you know,
he's doing really well,
but he was gone for
long stretches of time.
Oh,
away from his family.
And he wasn't getting to do much stand up.
And he and I had a conversation
about it and I said,
Stu,
I go,
you're too funny to be just
working for a television show.
Anybody can do a television show,
but not everybody could do stand
up the way you did stand up.
And um,
he somewhere along the line decided,
all right,
fuck this TV shit.
And uh,
I'm just gonna just gonna
concentrate on standup.
And a big part of that with social media,
so big part of it for him was,
you know,
every year we have this a sober October
crew where it's already Thompson for me
and Bert and we do a one month challenge.
Like it was last year was
a fitness challenge and
before that it was a hot yoga
challenge and before that,
um,
they had to lose weight.
So that's when we,
we've only done it twice,
but it's a big thing.
Social Media Wise,
a bunch of people hop on board with it,
a bunch of people join in and they
take a month off booze and to,
and,
and for Bert,
that's fucking hard.
That guy goes hard in
the paint with the booze.
So for him that,
that the sober October stuff and the
weight loss stuff propelled his career.
I mean everything started taking off the
Netflix special started taking off it.
Standup shows are sold out everywhere.
He,
people know him,
they know he takes off his
shirt when he goes on stage.
Now it's a totally different thing.
So I get it with him because that's what
brought him to the dance social media.
Absolutely.
And that guys figured it out.
I'm just using Burt as an example of a
guy who's social media a ton and it's
figured out a way to weave that into
his kind of aura and what he does
professionally.
But for me,
I feel,
I get a little,
I feel like everything I do on
social media has to be funny.
Like if I do a post,
I feel like it has to be funny.
I,
I feel a little bit intimidated to put
something out that's just me doing x,
y,
and Z.
And that's where I feel
I fail at social media.
And I feel like I've
kind of weaned off it.
And sometimes I look at my
Instagram or my Twitter,
it looks like a,
um,
I'm going to be here,
I'm going to be here.
Here's my shows.
There's no real kind of
substance to it at all.
Yeah,
that bothers some people,
but the good thing is,
I mean I get what people go,
Oh,
you do is promote your shows.
Yeah,
but I'm promoted my shows,
you know,
this is where I am.
She liked my shows.
That's where I'm going to be.
I get it,
but I see what you're saying as a comic
because our reach should fear said that
too,
like he doesn't want to put anything on
Instagram or Twitter unless it's funny
now that that's what he
concentrates on and he tries,
he was off even saying that he was going
to mock people that are comedians that
say things that aren't funny.
I'm like,
well then you're going to be mocking me.
I say a lot of shit that's not funny.
He's like,
yeah,
but you do other things.
Which is weird because
I do do other things,
whether it's podcasting all the
time or doing the UFC commentary,
like,
you know,
if I'm,
if I watch some fights and
I started posting about MMA,
I'm not trying to be funny and
it's just this is what it is.
Well,
yeah,
you're,
you're living in a lot
of different worlds,
but,
and,
and I look at your Instagram,
you're cooking meat,
right?
Yeah.
But for me,
I'm thinking,
how the hell does he get the meat?
Uh,
like from,
from top to bottom,
like medium rare throughout,
you know,
like that's for me,
that's more of a
shoe.
Sebastian,
I could teach you,
you know what the key is?
Cooking it slowly.
Okay.
So you got like this grill or whatever.
Yeah,
it's a pellet grill.
Pellet grill is a little bit,
if it gets my meat the way Jimmy,
well,
I'll have them send you 100%.
Perfect.
Um,
but yeah,
he's the only one of those are,
do you know how they work?
No.
Oh,
it's fucking fantastic.
It's,
it's uh,
the like say if someone wants
to make a desk like this,
I had a hardwood like this oak,
the saw dust,
they take the saw dust from,
from saw mills and they compress it and
they make these little tiny pellets.
And so there's no chemicals,
no nothing.
It's just wood.
And then the,
the way a pellet grill works is a bunch
of really good companies that make,
um,
uh,
I use a trigger,
but I've used a Yoder
that's a great one too.
And Green Mountain grills,
that's a great one.
This,
uh,
they have,
they all work the same way.
They have a heating
element and a worm drive.
So you have this big bucket of these
pellets and then the worm drive feeds the
pellets into this heating element and
the heating element makes the pellets
catch fire.
So once they catch fire,
it's a matter of how much pellets
and how much fan to keep the tea.
That's what it looks like up there.
So then let's see,
look at this job.
Yeah,
no,
I'm looking at this and I'm like,
that looks like a,
that looks like a lot of work.
First of all,
you've got to get a pet,
a side pellet,
the catchall,
but it's there.
It comes with the whole thing,
but then you've got to go by the pellets.
It sees,
I'll have it delivered to you.
I'll have it delivered.
I'm trying to get more people to cook
like this because it's just wood and fire.
It's the best.
There's no chemicals,
there's no bullshit,
no lighter fluid,
no gas,
no nothing.
So your NDA or me fire,
your entire meet process is on this
grill except the end at the end.
This is a different grill than I have
because this one has a thing on the side.
If you see the thing on the,
on the right hand side is
like a like that looks like a,
like a direct flame thing.
It looks like it's got gas as well.
Right.
The one that I have doesn't have that,
but at the end I,
I sear it at the very end
on a cast iron frying pan.
So I cook it from between
225 to 275 degrees,
which is pretty low and I'll kick it
until it hits an internal temperature,
depending on what I'm cooking.
Some are around one 22 the maximum,
like one 30 ish.
Then I take it out and then I have
a cast iron frying pan is hot as a
motherfucker and I use either a beef
tallow or grass fed butter and then I see
her that shit out of that with some
garlic and I throw some time in there and
fork and flip it over and get that good
seer and then I let it sit for a minimum
of 10 minutes and think,
just realized that model.
Oh,
okay.
So you're,
you're me is unbelievable.
I've seen it on the care
when you say that Instagram.
So I do something similar,
but I do it in the oven.
I don't do it.
That'll work.
I do a slow cook in the
oven and then I take it out.
I let it rest for I think 15
minutes and then I do a sear job,
but I'm always looking for better ways to,
to cook meat.
And uh,
if,
if you're saying that this Palette thing,
uh,
does it add any flavor?
And that's what's good about it
because it's smokey hardwood.
Gotcha.
So you're,
it's all smoke.
You lift the thing up,
smokes coming out of it and everything.
It's a nice aromatic,
smart,
that's what I know.
It's like cherry smoke or oak or you know,
Hickory or maple,
all these different hardwoods.
You could choose a bunch of different.
Perfect.
Okay.
So you're not getting that in the,
in the oven I need,
no,
it's different.
So a setting on a trigger called
super smoke where you hit it,
it goes to,
it can't be over 225,
but that's what I like anyway.
And you put it on two 25 and it just
constantly fans hard and pushes all this
smoke.
So it just gets his deep rich
smoky flavor in the meat.
Molly's nice.
But a,
I like,
if you're not into that too.
I like irregular Weber Grill.
Like one of those little
fucking Weber a that you know,
the little Hibachi.
Yeah.
What are those things called that you get?
What would you call them?
They'll like a drum.
Looks like a half a drum.
Like
a barrel fucking thing.
Yeah.
But what are the,
those,
those way it looks like it looks like a,
like a black uh,
yeah,
the black ones.
Yeah.
Nothing like steal those.
What I like those with,
uh,
just lump charcoal.
That puts a nice flavor on it too.
The key is don't fuck
around with the chemicals.
When you started using
lighter fluid and shit,
that,
that adds weird tastes to your food.
Yeah.
And even if you buy that lump charcoal,
those charcoal briquettes rather
the charcoal briquettes there's,
there's something in them
that makes them that shape.
They have to,
and then they,
they know they,
they lay light fast.
Yeah.
Cause there's fucking gasoline in them.
Like,
but lump charcoal meaning they just take
hardwood and then they burn that shit
down to,
you know,
that clunky looking lump charcoal.
Just get that stuff and then take some
newspaper and rolled a newspaper up.
And one of those you ever
used one of those little uh,
um,
those chimneys?
Do you know what those things are?
Yeah,
it's a barbecue chimney.
It's like a,
you pour the charcoal in this tube and
at the bottom of the tube you take like
pieces of paper and your crump alarm
up balls and then you like the balls on
fire and the fire rises up from the
paper to the charcoal and it likes to
charcoal on fire.
Then you dump the charcoal
out into the grill and that,
that puts a nice flavor on it too.
That's just a,
but it's again,
same kind of feeling.
It's like would just,
this would flavor on the meat.
It's nice.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm,
I'm a big fan of cooking.
I love it.
I went to this restaurant
the other night to
pls on it.
On Your Instagram.
Good meat.
I ate a 380 day dry age steak cheese.
This guy,
I'm going to get him on here.
He's a chef.
His name is Adam Perry Lang and he's
the guy who runs the place and uh,
I've never even heard of someone
doing something like that.
Like you hear like dry
age steak is like 30 days,
right?
He's,
he's taken it.
It's in some weird,
crazy place where he's got these,
these stakes in his gigantic like walk
in freezer era where everything is dry
aging.
They have certain microbes they put
in the air and then they have fans.
So it's like,
it's a certain type of bacteria that
they want that covers over the meet a
certain type of mold.
Oh Wow.
So delivers this very strange taste.
It's not like any steak that
I've ever had in my life.
It's very weird.
It's delicious.
That's what it looks like.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's 380 day dry age steak.
It's,
see,
it's,
he says it smells like fall gras.
It does.
It's,
it smells very strange.
It's very different.
And I've heard about this place,
um,
so phenomenal.
And I haven't been there yet.
Is this in Hollywood?
Right.
Thank you.
We'll go together after the show.
I'm ready to go home.
It's a,
it's on vine in Hollywood,
right?
Yeah.
It's phenomenal.
But it's,
it's not for everybody,
like flipped.
Like my wife is not into it.
She likes regular steak.
She's not,
it's like,
she's like,
ah,
yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's strong flavor.
It's a different flavor.
Like it doesn't taste like
anything you've ever had before.
venison doesn't taste like bison.
It doesn't take place like a robot that
you'd get from Fleming's or something
like that.
It tastes very,
very different.
Oh,
I love full graph.
It tastes like that.
Then I'm to sort of does,
but not really.
It smells like fall gras.
It's,
it tastes like itself.
It doesn't taste like
anything I've ever had,
but it's uh,
you know,
that's when you're,
you're fucking geeking out hard.
There's a shell that I
binge watch on Youtube.
It's called the meat show.
Um,
uh,
I think the youtube channels called eater
and then the show is called the meat
show.
And this guy just travels around going
to all these different super high end
restaurants that serve steak and trying
to see what their preparation is and
what they do differently.
And you could fucking
lose your mind with that.
Yeah.
You could go down a deep dark hole,
man.
Hey Man,
I'm,
I'm willing to try anything.
I'm more like a experimental as
far as when it comes to food.
My wife,
not so much.
He's very picky.
Do you use recipes,
use cookbooks?
Um,
I have used cookbooks in the past,
um,
but I do a majority of
the cooking in my house.
Uh,
I come from,
you know,
my mom used to cook a lot and uh,
and my father used to do a lot of fish,
so I don't do a lot of recipes.
It's more like dad,
how do you make the,
um,
the muscle,
uh,
for the mussel sauce and then he'll,
you know,
take me through it.
So nothing's written down.
It's
a lot.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What do you do?
Like what,
what do you end,
do you like look linguine with clams?
Like,
what kinds of stuff do you cook?
You know what I like?
I like a lot of pasta.
Um,
I like a nice bowl NEA sauce.
However,
I'm trying to stay away from those
types of meals because in the past I
ballooned up to two oh five,
two oh seven,
not giving a crap about my,
my health or,
or anything.
And recently I've lost some weight due
to the fact that I'm been watching my
diet.
Cause you know,
I mean,
I don't know.
I mean you're,
you're in shape,
so you,
you seem a lot more disciplined than a
lot of comedians when it comes to health.
But,
uh,
for myself,
I have,
you know,
taken on a regimen of
I'm not drinking a wine.
I used to having like a little wine
after the meal or during the meal.
So I've eliminated that.
And,
uh,
I've been doing some,
polities polite.
Yeah.
Nice.
Which has helped my,
uh,
my,
um,
balance and my core and
underrated exercise.
Very inelegant,
Italia Joe.
This polities is really changed
the way I look at the physical fit,
you know,
who's really into
[inaudible] Sergei Kovalev.
Really?
Yeah.
He just read,
regained the you the WBC or WB,
I forget which,
which light heavyweight
championship on a Saturday night.
He's,
the crusher is bad ass
Russian mother fucker.
And uh,
he just,
um,
just,
I mean,
at 35,
I think he has just regained his
title and his routines very unusual.
And one of the things that he does for
his exercise is policies and you know,
people make fun of it,
but the guy has got strength in all these
weird places and full range of motion
and flexibility and
well,
that's what I have.
I'm 45,
so my range of motion,
my,
my shoulders screwed up,
my legs,
my knee.
And this has given me an
exercise where I could,
uh,
not only improve my flexibility,
but man,
I mean,
you walk out,
I'm drenched.
Yeah.
And uh,
so yeah,
I'm getting back on the physical fitness
thing because I've been on the road
soul so much that I kind
of let that slip a little,
but I want to get the,
I want to get,
yeah.
You know,
some guys are real good about
working out on the road.
Like Brian Cowen goes everywhere.
He goes,
he'll go to a gym and
he's real good at that.
Like he'll go and,
uh,
go workout with kickboxers
workout with Jujitsu guys.
Brian does a lot of boxing,
so he'll find a,
like a local boxing gym and have
a guy hold the pads for him,
maybe dual,
even a little light sparring and
he gets really into it on the road.
But I think that's the key is like to
force yourself to not stay in your hotel
and wait until the show goes.
You just gotta Force yourself
to get out and go do something.
Yeah.
I wish I was a self motivated guy,
but I need help.
So I've taken a,
my buddy John Petrolia
is a personal trainer,
so he comes on the road with me and uh,
you know,
motivates me to,
oh,
that's great.
To get up and go.
We do swimming.
We do a lot of different things.
This guys,
I liken them to you because
he's into a mixed martial arts.
He's into hunting.
He's one of these guys that is a
great motivator and really helped me,
uh,
get my life back together when
it comes to physical fitness.
Because again,
I was lifting weights,
my everything was falling apart.
And now with the swimming and Palantir is,
I feel like a,
I have something to look
forward to when it comes to,
uh,
to,
to working out because I to go to the gym.
For me,
it wasn't fun anymore.
I was like,
what am I going do biceps and chest?
It's over.
I ain't,
I ain't do it to 25 ever again.
That's,
that was my workout since I was like 18.
I'd go in,
nothing.
Nothing changed.
It was two 25 and then
let's do some curls and a,
you know,
neglect the abs and go home.
The legs,
no legs.
Although I did have a,
I played soccer growing up,
so I did have those,
uh,
you know,
the soccer lakes,
I've got like Earl Campbell thighs.
Yeah,
soccer is one of the best exercises ever.
I mean,
it's also a great way
to blow your ACL out.
Totally.
Everybody's,
you know,
it's shifting left,
right.
And all that.
There's a fucking picture,
you know,
big boy,
the a,
the DJ,
his fucking son,
there's a video,
he retweeted it.
His son is a football
player and there's a,
there's a video of his son where you know,
someone's trying to tackle him
and he moves like a fucking ghost.
It's incredible.
You watch them.
Do I like it was one,
one of those rare things where you see
something and you're like legitimately
impressed.
Like Holy Shit,
I watched it like five times in a row.
This kid's foot work is incredible.
Yeah.
But footwork like that kind of like,
like who's in better
shape than soccer players?
They're constantly sprinting games
like you and you have to maintain that
stamina.
You're constantly sprinting.
Yeah.
There's a lot of mileage you're
putting on in us in a soccer game.
Although you know what gives me,
and you are probably going to
laugh as well as your listeners,
believe me,
pickleball,
you ever played pickle ball?
What does that pickle pickle ball.
It's like pennys and pink Pong
and you played in a gymnasium.
So it's like a,
it's a net.
Okay.
And it's,
you got paddles and talk
about moving side to side.
It's,
it's fun and you burn a ton of
calories and you do it in a gym.
You didn't have an gym and like a,
like a basketball court.
So it's like racquetball,
but there's a net,
there's a net.
So it's a bouncing off the wall.
You playing like tennis.
Yeah.
So court,
small net.
Okay.
And you have uh,
like in Venice,
those little small course it.
Why the old,
hello,
my name is Fred.
This is,
listen,
you're going to laugh.
All right.
There's a lot of old
people that play this,
but I'm telling you it's,
this is embarrassing.
So you each have your use for people.
Yeah,
you could do doubles,
but me and my buddy played just one
on one and I'm telling you it's not,
it looks like it's not only fun,
but you burn a lot of calories and you
don't even know you're doing it because
I'm diving and it's uh,
it's one of the exercises that we,
uh,
we really enjoy.
Got You doing,
he's got you doing
polities and pickle ball.
What's next?
I have no idea what he's working his way.
You know what he's working towards.
I don't have to tell you.
I'm calling you.
I know a lot of 68 year
old people play this,
but uh,
if you're looking for a low,
uh,
kind of impact,
fun activity,
uh,
it looks good if you're
looking at it and go,
oh it does.
Tennis is fucking hard,
man.
It's another thing.
This is like,
this is like tennis
reduced to a smaller court,
basically.
Probably Healthier for you and had it
not as hard on the ankles and the needs.
It's not as hard.
But uh,
I will have to go after we
have our steak over again.
Where would one go to and
of course in Venice beach,
that's what I thought it was.
I've always seen these small tennis
courts there and I didn't know really what
people were playing on.
They're calling it paddle tennis.
Yeah.
Maybe,
maybe this,
but this is what,
this is what it is.
These guys look ridiculous.
They should just go home.
This is outrageous.
What are you doing sir?
I'm telling you.
Put a little English.
Listen,
I grew up ping pong.
I'm really good at Ping Pong.
Yeah.
So this is like
a larger version of ping pong.
Yeah.
It looks like it's fun.
All bullshit aside.
That looks like a good time.
It's fun.
Believe me,
I know your listeners at
nigh and left and right now,
but I'm telling you it's,
it's uh,
it's,
it's good.
So that's what I'm doing show.
So you take your trainer with
you on your row on the road.
That's the move.
Where's this?
Where'd you meet this guy?
I've known him for 20 years.
I met,
I'm on the set of days of
our lives doing extra work,
shit days of our lives.
When I first came out to la in 1998,
I was the type of guy I would do
these weird like mailings to get work,
right.
So for days of our lives,
it was general hospital,
General Hospital,
take a headshot and then
take a post it note.
And I would write on a post
it note ready to operate,
stuck.
It could have had shot and I sat it out.
So I would do these like
weird little mailing.
We are only,
you know,
maybe the person opening
the mail would go,
oh,
I get a little chuckle and whatnot.
So I met him doing extra work.
This is what I used to do,
uh,
for,
for some extra cash.
And,
uh,
we became fast friends.
He's an Italian kid and
a w w similar upbringing,
middle class.
He's from New York.
I'm from Chicago.
And uh,
just a great,
great guy.
I,
he set me up with my wife.
I mean,
that's how I know my
wife threw him and uh,
he's been a huge,
huge help for me.
That's awesome man.
If you could find a guy who actually
knows what he's doing and that,
that is so huge because they
also know what you need,
you know,
they're like,
hey,
you know,
we need to concentrate more on your rear
delts and the issues you have with your
shoulders or your mobility.
So we're going to work
on some band work first,
warm you up and you could fuck
yourself up just doing it by yourself.
Really could.
I did,
and you're right,
he knows what to work on,
what to loosen up.
Let's not jump right into the exercise.
Let's warm it up a little bit.
So yeah,
I credit him to kind
of get me back on the,
on the,
on the health and fitness and
plus we were taking our own meals.
That's another thing.
Uh,
we were,
we pack our own meals,
we get like a service
and we bring a breakfast,
lunch and dinner on the road.
And that's our meals.
Oh,
you're taking it to another level.
Yeah.
Well,
well listen,
I was going out having a,
a dry aged at midnight.
I was eating a full blown steak,
asparagus and baked potato,
and then I,
then I would go to bed.
It sounds good.
It's delicious,
but you ain't got to in that,
you're bloody right.
That is true.
You know,
sometimes I will come home from the store
and I'm hungry and I'll eat late night
and then I'll wake up,
almost hung over.
I don't like what I didn't even try.
I ate,
I ate like a thousand calories
at two 30 in the morning.
Yeah.
Well last night my wife and I had Sushi.
I woke up and I don't,
the sodium was unbelievable.
I was like cheese from one thing as Sushi.
I look like a,
I need to go sweat.
And your son,
is it sodium and Sushi?
Like what's it's the soul.
It's this,
I'm the soy sauce and uh,
that's where at least
I'm picking it up from.
Who are all these guys
showing up at our door?
Hmm.
Okay.
Um,
does,
but sodium is,
what would it be in the soy sauce?
Right.
Green soy sauce.
That's like the low,
you know,
those have the low one and the high,
one of the two different kinds
of low sodium and high sodium.
I think last night I had the
high sodium and I woke up and uh,
it wasn't good.
How much soy sauce are you using?
You know what I like?
What do you like to soy sauce
and then I like the a Wasabi,
I put a clump it at,
in the soy sauce and then you mix it.
I mix it and make like a slurry.
Yeah,
it gets,
it gets a thick,
so when I eat the Sushi,
it just,
it burns my nose.
That's how I like,
I like it that way too.
Sometimes a Sushi chefs don't like it.
When you do that.
They get offended.
It's like what?
Disrespect and the fish
it should stand alone.
Did you ever see that
movie Jiro Dreams of Sushi?
Oh,
is that the guy that's got the
Sushi joint at the train station?
Yeah.
In Japan?
Have you seen that?
I've seen half of it.
It's really weird because it
changed my idea of what Sushi is.
I used to think,
oh,
they're cutting fish up.
They slap it on a piece of rice.
It's great.
It's good.
Tastes good,
clean,
easy for you.
Now I realize like this guy,
it's his,
like his lives dedication to
putting together the perfect tastes.
Yeah.
Like there was one guy that's been
working on this egg plate for a year,
trying to perfect it,
trying to get it right.
Similar to like a joke,
you know,
trying to make the joke so perfect.
I was trying to get the dish so perfect.
Um,
yeah,
and I would never thought that with Sushi.
With sue.
I thought like if you,
someone said a Sushi
chef,
I'd be like,
ah,
yeah.
Right.
Okay.
You're like,
he's not really a chef.
It's just cutting up fish.
Yeah,
but there's something about the
way they're preparing these.
I mean,
yeah,
it's one thing if you're
getting like a Sashimi,
it's just salmon,
but if they're putting it together
with rice and you know it's,
it's like a science.
Yeah,
no,
it's definitely a science.
It's also a science
because they age the fish,
which I didn't know.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
I was watching this youtube thing.
Oh,
where are these guys were going
to Sushi place and they were
saying that tuna,
they will have their tuna in the
frigerator for as long as two weeks in
preparation for Sushi and
just like dry age steak.
The aging of the tuna breaks down the,
the,
the bacteria break down some of the tissue
and make it softer and more delicate
and change the flavor profile.
Yeah.
No,
I have no idea.
I thought that caught it.
They don't,
don't you freeze fish for
it to be Sashimi grade is,
is that the deal?
I don't know.
Was that the case?
Let's find out what makes something,
it's just seemed great.
I saw there was a guy who caught a big
ass fucking tuna and they sold it for $3
million.
I had queued up and say,
yeah,
we'll go back to that.
Why in the fuck is that $5,000 a pound?
Japan's King of tuna.
Is that racist?
Uh,
the way I said it,
it seemed racist.
Uh,
the first tune,
the auction of the year,
a Tokyo's new fish market set a record
price more than 3 million for a giant
Bluefin tuna.
A critically endangered species.
Yeah.
See that's where you gotta go man.
Cause it critically endangered.
And if it's,
if it is,
so should you really be
cutting that fucker up?
I don't know about that.
When I was in Hawaii,
uh,
we caught some,
yellow tail.
My youngest daughter loves fishing,
so went out with her and we,
uh,
went on this boat and we
were actually jigging.
There's like this shelf in this
big dropoff in these yellow tails.
Hang out there.
We caught a gang of them and one of the
things they were saying was that the big
island had a farm where they were farming
yellowtail like they had this gigantic
like sort of netted in area where the
fish couldn't leave and they were,
they were trapped in this area.
But then the storm came and broke down
all the nets and the fish escaped and now
they're everywhere and
you're catching them.
We caught like I don't,
I'm like six or seven of them and they're
fucking pick like 10 pounds and you're
fighting them on like
a light spinning rods,
like really awesome,
awesome time.
But they were unbelievably
delicious but these are non native.
They brought him over there and released
him and like they'd been to start doing
that with other fish.
Like they really should set up these
fish farms and just released these
motherfuckers out into the ocean because
they're just taking nets and pulling
them across the bottom of [inaudible].
I don't even,
it's like such a,
there's something to be said about
going out and catching the fish,
like you're saying,
rather than taking a a net and just
scooping everything up in its path,
everything you think,
turtles,
dolphins,
whatever the fuck is there.
Everything gets jacked and the problem is,
you know,
there's,
who knows how many countries have boats
that are doing that and they're all
operating in international water and I
don't know what the fucking laws are,
but they're just pulling what and they,
you know,
the other thing they do that's
fucked up when they're done,
a lot of times they cut that,
the net loose and they
just leave it in the ocean.
They just dropped the net
to the bottom of the ocean.
It's funny they have the
regulations for like hunting.
Yeah.
They don't have it like in the
ocean because nobody owns it.
Yeah.
You only own like a certain
amount of your shore,
like ow off,
like say from Malibu out.
I don't know how much they,
the United States owns,
but we only own a certain amount and
then it becomes international waters,
international waters.
It's like kind of
anybody can be out there.
It's weird.
I mean it makes sense,
but there's no,
I don't think there's any,
I think if you have a boat you can just
kind of go anywhere that's international
water and just no regulations here.
What is,
what parts of the ocean are
considered international water,
territorial waters or territorial seas?
Defined by a 1982 United Nations
convention on the Law of the sea.
It's a belt of coastal waters extending
at most 12 nautical miles from the
baseline.
Usually the mean low water
mark of the coastal state,
so 12 miles or 12 miles out or
a 13.8 miles nautical miles.
Nautical Miles is different,
Huh?
Hmm.
Interesting.
Why is it different and how weird is that?
Nautical miles is different
than regular miles.
The fuck.
Get it together.
Don't call it a mile.
Then he fucks.
Imagine,
hey buddy,
I'll meet you at 12 miles.
All right.
12 nautical miles and the guys
at Mylon 0.8 away from you.
All those stores use the
label Sushi grade fish.
There was no official
standards for using this label.
The only regulation is that parasitic
fish such as salmon should be frozen to
kill any parasites for being consumed raw.
The best ones are assigned grade one,
which is usually what would
be sold as Sushi grade.
But what about Sashimi
grade is what he said.
It's the same thing.
So I looked up and that's what popped up.
You're not supposed to eat salmon raw.
Apparently salmon is a
freshwater fish and salmon.
It can fuck you up,
but you could pull a tuna out
of the right out of the ocean.
Yeah.
I have a buddy of mine who when
a tuna fishing off of San Diego,
they call it a tuna and they sliced it
up and ate it right there on the boat,
like right as they,
right after they pulled it out of the
water that I haven't done but the that
that to me would be the bus eating.
It's just out of the water.
I mean,
I just hope they don't wait until there's
nothing left before they start doing
something to save them.
It just doesn't,
it doesn't seem like the,
I mean,
if you're taking us fish and
you're buying it for $3 million,
that's almost like a scene in the movie,
right?
That's like the end.
This was one of the last tune I looked.
They bought it for 3 million.
Everybody's smiling and
they're cutting it up.
It's like,
Ooh,
hunting regulations are critical,
but you could,
you know what the population is.
It's very,
they do.
The fish and wildlife departments have
all these different methods they use,
whether it's,
I'm using reports from Hunter's,
whether it's a,
they fly over with airplanes and
helicopters and things along those lines.
Whatever they use,
they have a bunch of different ways that
they can determine what the population
is and then they determine
the population of predators,
how many animals are lost,
how many animals are shot
during hunting season.
And then the determine how
many tags can be divvied out.
So like say if you live in an area,
um,
there might be a 500 tags available,
but there might be like 2000 hunters
that are applying for those tags.
So most people are not going to get it.
It's a,
it's a,
a very smart way.
They've really got it down
to a science because of that.
There's more whitetail
deer in this country than,
than even when Columbus land.
It's a,
they've got a really good system.
If they could figure
something out for the ocean,
the problem is you'd have to get everybody
to cooperate and some like they can't
even get Japan to stop killing whales.
Like there's,
there's certain Japanese folks who,
uh,
they have this really sneaky
thing they do and there's this,
there's this,
um,
conservation group called
the sea shepherds and they
catch these fucking people
all the time.
But what they basically do is they say
we're a research boat and they use a
research boat and go slaughter
whales and then sell the whales.
But they pretend it's that it's research,
but if they kill a whale,
certain countries still
value parts of Wales.
They make things with it.
What the fuck do they make with whales?
I think they make some perfumes.
Like what?
But people are still killing whales.
He hits,
it gets weird when things are smart.
That's when it gets weird.
You know,
something as smart as a fucking whale.
Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
the end,
these in these countries,
they're using,
like you said,
parts of the fish for,
you know,
they put it on their mantle.
They got like a,
a,
I dunno,
a tooth.
Yeah.
Or,
or,
or what have you.
From a whale or a shark or whatever.
It was.
The big thing with rhinos guys,
the rhino horns off and they drink it
like in a tea and supposed to make your
dick hard.
Oh,
is,
see,
this is what I'm talking about.
You know,
these things.
I mean,
I don't know how to hell you
remember all this stuff I'm going to,
I've just forgot the
mileage off the coast.
Miles,
13.8 models.
Miles 12 nautical miles.
One point difference.
1.8 difference at 12 miles,
which is,
who knows how long.
When you get to 500 miles out,
you got to do the math.
It's crazy.
It's stupid.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
I don't,
I don't know how I remember these things.
It's a fucking screwy brain.
I wish I had your memory,
Joe.
That's what I'm saying.
It's not the best.
I'm telling you.
It's like they're so,
a lot of shit that I don't remember.
I just remember things
that are interesting.
You know,
I have,
uh,
it's,
it's an odd,
it's an odd sense of memory,
but the,
uh,
the Rhino Horn thing is kind of
sad because it doesn't even work,
you know,
especially in this day and age
where people can get Viagra.
That works.
Yeah.
But there's something about it,
I think in some Asian cultures where
it's considered like a sign of wealth,
you drive a Rolls Royce,
you drink rhino t this guy's a baller.
You know,
he doesn't give a fuck.
He drinks wine,
Ot,
you know,
like,
Oh man,
guys drinking rhino t what a guy.
Yeah.
This.
But there's something about that,
like,
you know,
yeah,
I want to eat an extinct animal.
I want to bring a woolly mammoth back
to life and shoot it in the head.
Like there's some people
that are like that.
Like they,
they want to be the ultimate conqueror.
And you know,
I want to eat a whale dick.
You know what I mean?
There's people that are like that.
I'm just looking for a nice steak.
Joanie stake are good
linguine with clams sauce.
That place that I saw you
at when I was with my kids.
A modality that's a
sensational Italian restaurant.
That place is legit.
Well that place moved.
Yes.
If you've been to the new habit.
So that place is excellent.
What's in the old spot there re where
you're doing the whole building.
I think that's one of the last times I,
I've eaten there when I
saw you and your kids,
uh,
having a meal there.
Uh,
yeah,
that place is good.
The pastas are fantastic.
As good as it gets.
It's delicious.
They make the perfect linguine with clams.
It's like perfect.
Not Too soupy.
You know,
some people get crazy with the,
the liquid and you get it and it's like,
it's,
it's almost like bathing in a,
in a soup and,
but they have,
it's nice.
It's Al Dente Day.
It's got some chew to it
and the place is authentic to,
I mean,
they got like guys walking around there
from like Sicily and Italy and the
owners,
a little old man that kind of walks
around and makes sure everything's okay.
And He's speaking Italian a yeah.
You feel like you're in a,
you're in Italy when her style,
but you know they're so,
you know.
Yes I did.
That's crazy.
You know,
I also saw their Shannen Doherty.
You remember her?
She was like two one on the original bad
girl that there's a lot of celebrities
at pop in.
I saw Jay Z and Beyonce come in on,
so Yay.
Come to the back door.
And he was looking at like a trap.
There was a battery
tunnel under the ground.
It's put the celebrities
and pop them up through now.
Oh Man.
So,
um,
what was it like doing
Madison Square Garden?
You did four shows in
Madison Square Garden.
He did it in the round.
Yeah.
So,
um,
how many shows you've done the
round before leading up to then?
I'd say probably 15.
16.
Oh,
so you've done quite a few in the rounds.
Do you like it?
Um,
it's a different animal and my act
is very physical and expressive,
so it kind of works for
that type of environment.
Uh,
although you have to listen,
there's a screen above you,
so people are watching screens
when they go to shows anyway.
Uh,
but the challenge to do it in the round
is to hit those people within the first
five rows that maybe can't see this
screen because once you go to the side of
the stage,
you got your back to them and it's,
it's kind of difficult to you there.
Yeah.
Wow,
that's so crazy.
That's 18,000 people.
That's fucking bananas,
Dude.
So yeah,
it's been for New York.
New York for me has been really,
really good to me over the years.
Um,
obviously I'm Italian and there's a lot
of Italians in the New York City area.
But what I think has happened is I'm
talking about like family and I'm talking
about late,
the immigrant experience.
Uh,
my father being an immigrant from Sicily.
And what I'm seeing at my shows is
not only an 88 year old grandmother,
but a 12 year old kid and
kind of everybody in between.
So it's very broad.
It's comedy and I'm not
tooting my own horn here.
I'm just saying it's comedy that you
could come and not cringe because the
material might be a little blue
or what have you and ideas.
Imagine if you had Julie Diaz.
Oh,
before you amass soccer.
Yeah,
there'll be a little shocked.
Oh my God.
So yeah,
I mean that's why I think I was able to
do four shows at Madison Square Garden
just because my audience is a
large swath of multigenerational.
Uh,
it's multi generational,
it's just a lot of different
people at the shows and um,
to do Madison Square Garden for me,
as we were talking prior
to getting on here,
I was saying that I think I took
a little too much on my plate.
And what I mean by that is
coming up in comedy,
I used to say yes to everything.
The phone used to ring and it
was my agent you want to do,
yeah,
put me down.
I'm in when you're trying to work,
trying to work and what has
happened once you get too busy,
I think,
uh,
you need to learn to press
the brakes a little bit.
So,
uh,
I did a ton of press when I was in
New York and I had family there,
I had friends there and I think I
spread myself a little too thin.
So when the shows came,
I don't feel like I was
operating at an optimal level to,
to perform.
Yeah,
it was fun.
I still had a good time.
But you know,
the more and more I do
stand up to more and more,
I feel like you really got to be
clearheaded in the moment and you can't,
you can't overwork yourself.
It's just who I am.
I've always been a worker.
I mean,
when I wasn't going to college
and I had time off in the summer,
I was working,
uh,
when I,
I used to work summers as a
janitor during high school,
so all the time was
always occupied with work.
And I feel if I'm not working,
I feel like,
or I'm not doing press or I'm not doing,
uh,
anything,
I feel like I'm slacking.
Yeah.
I feel like,
because my father has
always put it in my head,
you know,
what do you,
what are you doing?
Like he'd come home and go,
what'd you do today?
And I'm like,
yeah.
It was like,
all right,
you know,
you're going to paint the fence this,
this weekend,
I'm going to paint the fence.
So there was always something to do and
that work ethic has bled into my career
and now that I've had
some success in my career,
I think I have to kind of pull it back
a little bit and not say yes to an
interview that maybe,
you know,
he's not going to help,
but he's going to take
up a lot of your time.
Yes,
exactly.
Yeah.
No,
I'm in the same boat.
And,
uh,
I mean,
I think sometimes even
I do too many podcasts,
I think.
Um,
but there's a lot of fucking
people I want to talk to,
so it's hard.
But I think,
um,
I've,
I've definitely stopped doing interviews
and all those different things for that
reason.
It's just there's only certain
amount of time you have and you know,
like you,
I have a family,
I exercise and I have a lot of hobbies,
man,
between archery and martial arts and,
and reading and just watching
documentaries and you know,
it's,
is it going to help?
Like I don't want to be any more famous,
you know,
we were talking about this earlier.
I don't,
it's good.
I'm working.
It's all I want to do.
What I want to do now is do my best work.
Yeah.
That's my number one objective.
Whether it's stand up,
whether it's UFC commentary,
whether it's doing a podcast.
I want to do my best work and I don't
think that I can do my best work if I'm
scattered.
And I often am.
I think you put the,
hit the nail on the head
doing your best work,
whatever you're doing.
So if you're kind of come in
here today and do a podcast,
whatever you did prior to this cannot
really take away from the energy that you
need to do this.
Same thing with the MMA
and then the announcing.
And the same thing with
the standup comedy.
I feel that sometimes I jeopardize
myself and I take on too much and I've
realized that and I'm going to kind of,
cause now I got to fuck
another baby coming.
So thank you.
Family's growing.
And you know,
I come home and I'm
looking at my daughter,
she's 20 months and I mean,
those moments for me are like,
do I,
do I want to like take my daughter out
for lunch or do I want to do an interview
in a,
I had a whole know,
I know you've got to sell tickets.
That's part of the game.
But I think I need to kind of,
uh,
just choose my,
my,
my roads a little careful.
Well,
that's one of the good things about
social media is that it allows you these
paths,
uh,
to distribute,
you know,
like flyers and you'd put a little posters
of where you're going to be and stuff
like that.
And it can reach your actual
fans as opposed to just,
you know,
random person who's
listening to the radio.
A random person picks up the newspaper.
That's what I think that,
but,
but I like to reach the person
that doesn't know who I am.
It's fun to go to your fan base,
but you know,
I'm sure a lot of the people that listen
to your podcast maybe not know who I
am.
And it's a joy for me to
get someone who is this guy,
maybe check them out and to get a new fan
opposed to maybe feeding the fan base.
I currently have.
I'm always looking for new people,
uh,
to,
to come on board with what I'm doing.
So,
uh,
you know,
when I do a radio show in Peoria
at seven o'clock in the morning,
I'm hoping someone's in their
car going check 'em out.
Yeah.
And even if it was two people
that bought the ticket for me,
I would think that it was worth
it getting up to get to more fans.
Sometimes though it's it,
it's,
it hurts the end product.
And the reason why I'm
here is the standup comedy.
If that starts to slack then
everything else falls apart.
Yeah.
I feel the same way and I've,
I've learned over the years what the,
what the mistakes are like
where I can screw it up.
Like podcast for instance.
I don't do like a,
I used to do like a hot
yoga class at 10 30.
It gets out at noon.
I do a podcast at one.
I can't,
I don't do that anymore because I found
I was just too fucking worn out cause I
do a 90 minute yoga class and um,
I come in here and I'm still like,
oh yeah,
what,
what do you,
what are we talking about?
Like I'm still spacey.
I need two hours,
I need two hours and I need to drink a
shit load of water and then I'm good to
go.
But I need that extra hour.
So now I'll do like an eight 30
class or something like that,
or maybe even a six in the morning class.
And so when I have a 1:00 PM podcast,
I'm fucking completely acclimated.
But I had to do that by trial.
Absolutely.
And that's where I'm at.
I think I'm trying to figure out what,
what the balances of,
of,
of creating a life outside of stand up
and then giving all I can to stand up.
And even I do a podcast,
uh,
with Pete Cory Alley that,
we did a live podcast for the first time.
And I don't know if you've seen this,
the podcast listener is
a different audience than
what's arriving at my shows to
different audiences.
There's a,
there's a,
there's a definite podcast
listener out there.
I mean,
people that listen and consume
podcasts and it crosses over,
don't get me wrong,
but I,
I went to do the podcast in
Orlando and totally different,
totally different vibe.
It's nice to see who the hell
is listening to this stuff.
And we did it.
And I don't know if you've
ever done a live cast,
but I'm sure you're,
you're,
you're like an anomaly.
I,
you got like fans from all
different walks of life.
I mean,
you're in the standup world,
you're in the,
uh,
mixed martial arts world
here in the podcast world.
So it must be a lot of different
people coming to your shows.
It was a lot of Weirdos.
If you see a dude,
a shaved head
and tattoos and he's kind of jacked,
he probably knows who I am.
But it's like a lot of people that are
into the science podcasts or the F,
you know,
podcasts with a interesting intellectual.
So there's just like,
there's a lot of,
yeah,
but there's people that don't like
the mixed martial arts stuff and they,
they like me for other things.
You know,
it's,
it's hard.
You can't please everybody,
you know,
it's not really possible.
And then along the way,
you find that out and you
piss a bunch of people off.
You know,
they're like,
you know,
I don't like that part of you.
Like,
okay,
I don't know what to tell you.
You can't make everybody here know what,
especially if you do a lot of shit,
you know.
But,
um,
I'm lucky with the job with the UFC that
they don't really care about the other
things that I do because if I was working
for a more sensitive organization,
you know,
obviously it's a fucking
cage fighting promotion.
It's like how sensitive can you get,
but with some social issues,
you know,
it's like if I was working for the NBA,
I probably have been fired a decade ago.
Yeah.
It easily,
the NMA is definitely a or that UFC
is definitely an animal in itself.
How did,
how did you get into that position?
Did you know the Dana White
and you started for you,
I always wanted to ask you this
and that at the comedy store,
how did you become kind of the voice of,
of the UFC?
Well,
I started a,
in 1997 I was the post fight interviewer.
That was,
uh,
it was just a position that was available
in the UFC was very small back then.
Very few people knew what it was.
It was off a cable.
You couldn't get it on cable,
you could only get it on satellite.
And uh,
they needed someone to
do post fight interviews.
So you were in that world to begin with.
I was in the martial arts world.
You know,
I used to teach martial arts for a
living before I became a comedian.
I used to fight a fight in Atlanta,
taekwondo tournaments and had some
kickboxing fights and I'd always been a
martial artist since I was a kid.
And so,
um,
I just was interested in watching the UFC
and then I started training in Jujitsu
and when I was training in Jiu Jitsu,
I was just a white belt,
was just starting out.
That's when I got hired by the UFC
to be a post fight interviewer.
But I only did that for
two years and then I quit.
It was just too much and
it was actually like,
it was,
I was losing money.
I would make more money,
uh,
doing a weekend at a comedy club,
then I would doing it doing the UFC.
And it just got to a
point where it's just,
it was too much of a pain in the ass.
And so,
uh,
I still remained a fan,
but I backed away.
And then the UFC was purchased by this
company called Zoo Fhfa in 2001 and when
that happened,
um,
they started putting on shows in Vegas.
I would go there with my friends.
They got me free tickets,
they reached out and they would try to
get celebrities to go sit there so that
it would,
cause they were very small at
the time and they were trying,
they were hemorrhaging money and
they're trying to build it up.
And in talking to Dana White one day he,
you know,
I was talking to him about fights
going on in Japan and like,
have you ever seen Sato fight?
Do you know what,
what do you do?
You know,
soccer rod,
you know,
this guy at night.
And it was bringing all
these names and he was like,
do you want to do commentary?
I'm like,
I don't want to do commentary,
man.
I'm,
I'm here to get drunk and watched
people kick the shit out of each other.
I'm not here to work.
And he talked me into it for one show,
UFC 37 and a half.
It was a show that was on,
I'm one of those,
uh,
Fox sports networks,
smaller networks.
And um,
I think it was the best damn sports
show period was a part of it.
I did that and the rest is history.
And then I did like 12 of them for free.
Like the UFC didn't have any money.
Well,
they were hemorrhaging money and they had,
they were rich people that owned it,
but it was not a profitable venture.
And I said,
look,
just get me there.
Get me and my friends
tickets and I'll do it.
And so that's how I operated for like,
oh,
like over a year.
And then I just became the commentator.
It's just weird.
That's crazy.
It's just Dana White,
he's,
he's a crazy man and he's a,
he's got a weird way of
looking at things that,
that's very effective.
And in his crazy mind,
he's like,
let's take this guy who's never even
thought about being a commentator and make
them our commentator.
I mean,
I didn't know what the fuck I was doing.
I really didn't,
I didn't have any training
at all in sports commentary.
I just would see what was happening
and start talking about it,
you know,
which is really like the wrong,
I was more even play by play and color.
It was like doing both
of them at the same time.
It was really weird.
And as far as you doing that,
do you get any notes from anybody going,
hey Joe,
a try this,
try to add or you just develop that whole,
that voice all on your own?
100% of my own.
So the only thing that I had was,
uh,
there's like mark della grotto,
who's a good friend of mine.
He is,
um,
he's,
uh,
one of the top trainers in the world.
He's in the truck and uh,
I can communicate with him.
There's a button where I can communicate
with him and we talk about stuff like I
can say,
uh,
does he look like he's limping to you?
And he's like,
yeah,
there's something wrong with his leg.
I go to the left leg,
right?
He's like,
yeah,
yeah.
And then I'll start talking about it.
Like I'll,
I'll be able to bounce it
back and forth with him.
Or sometimes I just,
it's obvious and I'll say it myself,
then I'll,
I'll ask him like it,
am I wrong?
Is he dropped in his hand or is this like,
is a nice,
it's a nice thing to have
someone to bounce things off.
It used to be Eddie Bravo,
Eddie Bravo used to do it as well,
where I would uh,
be able to talk to him about certain
positions because he would be in the truck
and I'd be able to ask him like,
uh,
which his left leg is
in jeopardy right now.
Right.
Or He needs to step
over with his right leg.
We'd be able to go over because it's
like there's some aspects of martial arts
that are extremely technical,
especially Jujitsu.
When things go to the ground and you're
trying to commentary do commentary.
And I have to decipher
which is his left leg,
which is his right leg,
where is he tied up?
Where's he tangled?
And I'm doing it in real time while I'm
trying to be entertaining and talking.
It's very complicated,
you know,
but nobody taught me how to do it.
I just figured out how to do it.
And you're not looking at it like,
uh,
Jim Lampley or anybody in the
broadcasting world when it comes to of it.
This is something that
you developed on your own.
Like sometimes you look
at it as a comedian,
you look at other Comedians,
say the priors are Carlin's or whatnot.
Do you didn't have the kind of like a,
a mentor?
No,
not necessarily because there wasn't one.
Um,
there wasn't a lot of guys that did it in,
in for martial arts commentary.
There was,
um,
John Perretti who was excellent.
He was one of the very best who was
actually the UFC matchmaker and a
commentator when I first started.
He was very good.
Uh,
there's a guy named Jeff Armstrong.
He was very good too.
He was there when I first started to,
he actually ran a promotion
called Hook and shoot.
He's excellent.
He really knows what he's doing.
And then there's a few other guys,
you know,
the,
that also did it,
but there's like what I do
as far as like Stan doing,
um,
uh,
commentary for MMA.
There's might maybe 10
guys in the world to do it.
Yeah.
You know,
that really do it on a high level.
Maybe 10 guys.
Whoa.
I mean,
between one FC,
uh,
between,
um,
you know,
uh,
brave and then the UFC Bella
tour PFL there's maybe,
maybe 10 guys on the
planet that are doing it.
She's not a lot of people and
there's a lot in the UFC now.
We're fighters are now transitioning
to become commentators and oftentimes
they're the best at it.
Like Michael Bisping just
did this past weekend.
He was the UFC middleweight champion
and he's awesome at it already did.
One one show,
they know more obviously
because they've been in there,
you know,
they've,
they have that added element of
actually having fought in the UFC,
which is gigantic.
Yeah.
I could see,
uh,
I think Pauline [inaudible]
Mala noche he can,
he seems to be very,
very noticeable.
Yeah.
He's very good.
He's very good,
very technical,
but also very aware and fighters can
see things that maybe the average person
can't see.
Like they see when someone's slowing down,
they see when someone's laying back,
they see when someone
got hurt to the body,
they see like little things that may
be a person who's never fought before.
It doesn't say,
yeah,
the knowledge is key.
And plus the,
uh,
the excitement level too.
I mean,
when,
when someone gets hit for the announcer
to like react to that and in a real way
for,
for an audience member,
it's like,
you know,
it's,
it's exciting.
Yeah.
No,
that's what's up.
Yeah.
Like when,
so if someone's boring and bland and
they don't really care what's going on in
the audience feels it and they
feel it when you're faking it too.
Yeah.
If you try to pump it up and fake it.
Do you have any other hobbies
outside of a comedy and,
um,
I'm not a big hobby guy.
Growing up,
my parents always used to say,
d did,
what are you interested in?
Do you do anything?
So I gotta be happy now.
Yeah,
no shit.
Look,
it worked out.
My hobby is a standup comedy really.
I mean,
um,
I like to cook,
don't get me wrong.
I like to travel.
Um,
my wife and I really,
really enjoy going to different places.
And,
uh,
I love hotels.
It's a,
I mean,
these aren't really hobbies.
It's just a,
I like hospitality.
So that's my,
that's my passion.
Uh,
I like having people over at the
house and I'm making them feel good.
That's,
that's what I like to do.
I like to entertain.
Um,
if I find out you like a specific
drink or you like something that's,
uh,
you know,
I,
I take,
I take notice of what people like.
So when you come to my house,
I got what you like there.
That's very talented,
very,
very Italian.
And,
um,
I've always had,
you know,
I worked for the Four Seasons Hotel and a,
that chain taught me to
anticipate people's needs.
So anytime I have anything at my house,
whether it be a birthday party,
get together,
if it's going to be a fight,
I make sure when you come over you are
taking care of not only with your alcohol
needs.
Here's one.
I ain't a punt gay.
Right?
I don't,
I don't smoke pot.
We want to start,
listen,
but I ain't got pot at the house
just in case you want some really?
So I thought,
you know,
you have alcohol,
you have beer,
you have scotch,
you have wine.
So what if,
what if someone doesn't have a taste
for alcohol and they want a joint?
Wow.
I've got a couple of joints.
We get it from PDC,
from the comedy store.
I think I got it from,
you know,
from
though,
I think it's the,
what's the Med med men.
Yeah.
I went in there.
We went in there specifically
just for hospitality.
Hospitality.
If you came over and I go,
Joe,
you want to join and be like,
hey,
you want to smoke?
No,
I don't smoke.
But you know,
there have an edit just to have,
uh,
even as the guy got cigars.
I don't smoke cigars.
You want one?
I,
I dunno.
I get,
I get joy in making others happy.
So when you looked at your house,
did you look at your house and go,
this is a good house to entertain in?
Ah,
yeah,
we see that.
Like when you see like a youtube video
and a home and they're showing the home.
So a wonderful entertainers home,
like an entertainer's home.
What does that mean?
A Sanger
guys playing the piano.
It was,
I mean,
I like,
I like a living room that
bleeds into the kitchen.
All right.
That's,
that's,
I like that,
right?
There's not really a,
a,
a wall in between the two.
It's got to be,
and then I like indoor outdoor.
He live in California.
I liked it outside.
Maybe you want to have a drink
outside and bring it back in.
Just like the different,
that's what they want.
That's what they're talking
about when it's there.
I like a fire outside.
Oh,
fire,
pit,
fire pit.
Do you try to bring people,
like if you have a party,
do you try to bring people over that
you think would have interesting
conversations?
Yes.
Um,
although we have a problem
at this particular point,
we're in a transition period.
Um,
we have a child,
so I don't know if you went through this,
but a lot of,
uh,
sometimes when you're coming from s on a
single couple but a couple with no kids
and now you have kids,
now you're,
you're finding other people who have kids.
Right?
So that's what we're in.
We're a,
we're not yet into the preschool.
Uh,
so we're kind of in limbo.
We're looking for new friends
that are old friends are,
are bad.
It's just now we have other obligations.
We have a child,
we can't,
we maybe can't go out at the dinner at
eight o'clock at night like we used to
now.
Now we're looking to
bring it to the house.
Yeah,
no,
I know exactly what you're saying.
We went through that exact same transition
and a lot of times you pick up some
dead weight along.
No Way.
You run into these people and the only
thing they have in common is the kids are
the same age and then you have
to talk to some fucking guy.
Oh.
And they give you ear beatings about
their job and just like [inaudible] just
some people just not interesting.
It's unfortunate.
Yeah.
I mean you do run into
that where you meet a guy,
like I went to a toddler group,
uh,
last week.
Now some,
sometimes I do this obviously because
I want to hang out with my daughter.
But sometimes the material that comes on
at going to something like that is gold
now lets me 15 women and a
gay guy at this toddler group.
Right.
So I mean it's just like,
it's almost writing.
It's like writes itself.
Although I'm in a,
in a circle sitting Indian style,
hell,
I,
it's,
it's strange,
but man,
it's,
that's the things I want to do because
I feel if I live more of my life,
I could draw so much more humor from it.
It's,
it's a,
it's,
it's two pronged.
It's,
I want to hang out with
my family and I want to,
I don't want to talk to people who are
living these life experiences because
what I've noticed is I want to keep the
same kind of lifestyle I've had when I
wasn't successful because I feel the one,
you start detaching yourself
from the daily routine,
let's say even going to target.
If you have somebody go to target for you,
you don't,
you miss out on like what happens on a
day to day and I want to still keep that
rich and,
and,
and uh,
available to me.
That's very wise of you.
That's very true.
That is something that happens when
people become more and more famous,
especially they become more
reluctant to go places.
Like they just,
they don't want to just go to the mall,
you know,
like sometimes you just
got to go to the mall.
Yeah.
It's good.
It's good around Weirdos.
It's
good.
Well,
I think it was you.
Yeah,
it was you saying that like if you were
out at a restaurant and somebody comes
up to you and asked for a picture because
everybody wants a picture nowadays the
to approve,
they met Joe Rogan and,
and what have you.
And sometimes it's a little intrusive
when you're having dinner with your
daughters or your family.
And then it's like,
you know,
I've had people ask me for pictures when
my daughter's on my lap and I'm feeding
her.
Yeah,
look man,
you can't,
you gotta get the fuck out of here.
The problem is you take that picture
with that guy and then someone says,
oh,
I want a picture too.
And then you get 10 people to
get up and it sounds braggy,
but it's not,
it's just,
it's a weird thing that happens
with people with phones.
Half those people don't
even give a fuck about you.
They really just want to take a
picture with someone that they saw,
you know,
on fear factor whenever and they just,
Oh,
there he is.
Let me take a picture with them.
And they'd come over to your table and
they seem to think that it's part of the
job that you have to be,
every time you're in public,
you have to be available to them.
It's very weird like brule
that people have decided,
some fairly ignorant people have decided.
So that's why they would think that
even with my daughter on my lap,
and I'm literally,
but this was,
I was literally putting food into
her mouth and a guy was like,
hey man,
can I get a picture?
Like this is,
this is not a good time.
It's not a good,
this is not a smart thing to ask.
And it's why people,
certain people are reluctant
to go out in the first place,
why they're reluctant to go on public.
But do you feel an obligation to at
all to your fan base to make yourself
available to them?
If,
if I'm not with my kids?
Yeah.
So do you do generally turn
down any photos or autographs?
It has to
be an extenuating
circumstance for me to say no,
but there has to be something wrong.
Like,
if someone,
you know,
if someone is somewhere where
they're not supposed to be,
you know,
like,
like I had a guy come
backstage at the comedy store,
what made,
made it backstage all the way to the back.
And uh,
he's,
he's talking and I'm like,
dude,
I was asked the other times,
you know,
this guy,
do you know if the guy who is guy,
I go,
who are you man?
And he's like,
Oh,
I'm friends with this guy.
I go see,
just walked back here.
I'm like,
you gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
Like,
get Outta here man.
And then the security
comes and kicks the guy.
I'm like,
what is happening here?
Like this,
there's no security here.
Like that guy didn't ask for a photo,
but if he did,
I probably,
I probably take a picture
with that motherfucker,
but I'd probably take a
picture with them out there.
You know,
it's,
if you're in a rush for trying to go
somewhere and you're literally running and
someone wants to pull their phone out,
like sometimes you can't.
But most of the time,
if I'm by myself,
I'm very approachable.
Yeah,
it's just family stuff.
It's just like my kids don't like it.
Like especially my youngest daughter.
She does not like it.
She gets angry.
She squeezes my hand because people ignore
her and they just start talking to me
and she just standing there and
eight year olds have zero patients.
She sitting there going,
boom,
she doesn't give a fuck.
If they know me like to her,
I'm just dad and know like it
doesn't matter if I'm famous,
it doesn't mean anything to her.
What it means to her is
like when she's with me,
she likes attention.
She wants me to talk to her about stuff.
We have a nice little relationship.
Yeah.
I love having little people.
It's fun.
It's like it's,
it's a,
it's a for people that are single and I
think it all depends on where you are in
life and you know how
reflective you are about it.
For people that are single,
they look at at,
and I know I did,
they look at it as a potential burden.
Cause when I was a kid I
thought of myself as a burden.
So I think of other children as a burden,
but then you have them yourself.
And this,
the love that you have
with them is indescribable.
It's just crazy feeling that you didn't,
didn't even know was in the,
the menu before.
And then all of a sudden you have this
crazy feeling to this little person.
It's your favorite thing to do.
Yeah,
it is amazing.
And then to echo those thoughts,
uh,
I wasn't a big kid guy.
I was like,
I don't really need
kids and this and that.
But then you have them and you're like,
man,
what a missing this would be if you go
through life and you don't have a child.
And,
and I'm just,
I'm not saying you need to
have a child to be complete,
but for me,
man,
it's been,
it's been fantastic.
Uh,
and uh,
you know,
having a baby boy and I'll
come in on the way is a,
you know,
it's great.
I mean,
it's not a burden.
It's,
it just adds to your life.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's responsibility.
It's so overwhelming responsibility.
I mean,
it's not about you,
it's about them.
And,
uh,
you know,
you have to have a sense of,
um,
I don't know why you got to give them
the time they need in order for them to
succeed in life.
And,
uh,
you know,
my parents gave me,
gave me a lot of attention.
I mean,
my dad was the type of guy that,
uh,
was not really around because
he was working and my mom
was kind of managing the
house.
Um,
but over the course of,
of time,
my father and I become best friends.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
he's,
he's a huge critic of
what I do for a living.
I don't know if you have parents that
are heavily involved in your career,
but man,
my father,
he's,
you know,
he comes to,
he comes to the,
to the,
it's taking notes at the shelf.
So he's one of these guys.
He'll tell me if I suck.
I mean,
it's good.
It keeps me level headed.
You know,
I have a family that is a very,
very honest,
and they don't pull any punches and
people confuse that with being cruel.
Honesty.
Yeah.
Listen,
my father,
uh,
and my relationship
with my father has been,
and I had to tell him,
I said,
dad,
you know,
just could you come to just be
a fan and not like a father?
Just enjoy the show.
You don't have to,
you know,
critique it.
Uh,
which,
you know,
he has backed off,
but I know deep down
he's dying to tell me.
I mean,
uh,
I know when I do something
on TV and if you don't like,
say nothing about it,
he don't like it.
You know,
let's say if,
let's say if you listen
to this interview and,
and,
and then,
uh,
we talk and he owns some bring it up.
I know he's going to say,
you sucked.
It was no good,
boring,
boring was shut it off.
Why?
People want to listen to you.
He'll,
he'll give it to me.
But that's also why you're so funny
because you grew up with that.
That's part of the whole program.
Totally,
totally.
I mean,
I think that's a huge reason
why I am the way I am,
because I'm kind of honest.
Uh,
when I'm talking about comedy on stage,
the honesty is to me the,
the,
the funny,
the funniest stuff I got,
is this the truth?
And if you don't speak the truth then
I don't think it's particularly funny,
at least in my life.
But uh,
yeah.
To,
to come from that.
Um,
yeah,
my sister,
my,
my wife,
you know,
they'll tell me.
Yeah.
My wife will tell me to,
my wife's fucking funny.
She's hilarious.
She says ridiculous shit all the
time and she's getting good at it.
Like she,
she likes to make me laugh,
so like she'll point it something to
look at this mother fucker and like,
then we'll both start cracking up.
That's huge too.
And she'll tell me like if he
seemed a little off tonight.
Yes.
New Shits.
Especially when I have new material,
man's slippery,
you know,
new materials,
like I can't quite grab ahold of it.
It's like I know something's there,
but,
and the only thing that makes
it better is trial and error.
That's the only thing
that makes it better.
It's the only thing just
fucking constantly doing sets,
you know.
I know you're at the store all the time
and you work in other clubs as well
around town.
I'd just like to see the motherland dis
that stage in the original original room
for whatever reason I feel the most
comfortable and the most creative.
I'm not saying I won't do the ice house,
so stuff like that.
But it's,
it's,
it's easy.
It's,
it's kind of near where I live.
I bounce in,
I bounce out and uh,
I like,
I like doing it there
and I used to bring my,
my wife there when we didn't
have a baby and my wife I think,
and I don't know if your wife has,
uh,
did you think your humor
has like bled into your,
your wife's cause my wife's looking
at the world completely different.
Like a comic.
Yeah.
My wife's like a comment.
Yeah,
she thinks like a comic.
Yeah.
So definitely not true if you're
around comics all the time.
You think like comics,
like when comics come over the house,
she's always fucking with them.
It's hilarious.
She'll start poking fun and numb
and j she gets a kick out of it.
And when she's with her friends,
she's absolutely the one who's
always talking shit and making,
making people laugh.
That's funny.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
it's the most fun group of people to
be around when we're all at the store,
when we all see each other.
I mean,
it's,
one of the things that makes me feel so
fortunate is that I have so many friends
that are hilarious.
Like when I go there,
I see these guys and I
know that we're going to,
we're going to have some fun.
We're going to,
we're going to do sets,
but we're also going to hang out in that
back bar and talk shit and laugh a lot.
It just,
it's,
that's a great friendly environment,
you know?
And I like to laugh.
I love to ask.
So when I go to the comedy store,
I don't really,
if I'm around Comedians,
I don't say much because I,
I'd,
I'd rather sit back and enjoy
what's happening in front
of me that actually be a
part of it.
Because for me,
you know,
I make people laugh all the time and to
be around five or six comedians in the,
in the parking lot of the comedy store
and watch whatever you go off on a
tangent or cat,
Callan start,
you know,
doing his thing.
I just sit back and enjoy it.
I,
I don't like to speak around.
I like to go when I'm in the main room,
I like to go into the,
uh,
to the or and sit in the back
and watch the show sometimes too,
when I know I'm not going up
at all that night in that room.
I'd like to,
I like to do that.
I like to be an audience member.
I still really enjoy that.
It's still really enjoy just sitting in
the back with a drink and just laughing.
It's great.
It's a great thing to be a part of the,
you know,
he's fucking murder in it these days.
Neil Brennan,
Neal Brennan's on fire right now.
He's on fire.
He's doing really,
really well.
I think that special on Netflix,
the three mikes has really opened himself
up to performing in front of large
audiences and he's always
been a real funny cat,
you know?
I mean,
uh,
always been real funny,
but he's in a new zone right now.
We were,
I was watching him the
other night in the AOR.
I was sitting in the back of my,
God damn,
this new stuff is good to hear.
That's just such a fucking,
it's such a great hot spot.
There's so much good comedy
going on in that place,
whether it's Santino Santina
has been murdering lately.
Hinchcliffe cliff's been killing it.
There's just so many good comics there.
It's like a,
it's just,
you feel like it's,
it's fuel.
It's inspirational.
Yeah.
You walk in and see some guy
and going up and you're like,
man,
that's,
that's some funny stuff.
And you feel inspired to go and go,
I'm,
I'm going to write something
new or what have you.
It's nice.
It's a nice community to be
a part of that comedy store.
It's really helped me
over the last 20 years.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
it's very unique,
you know,
and uh,
I showed you that a painting that a
Taylormade that I posted up on Instagram.
That's the painting of Mitzi.
I think I'm going to put that
motherfucker right there.
That's nice.
Mitzi watch over us.
Yeah.
This,
this whole thing you've got going on here.
And I don't know if
he'd talk about it much.
I don't know if you're private about it,
but even being here in
this studio is inspiring.
When I,
when you were showing me
what you have and whatnot,
I'm like,
man,
see,
I don't,
I've always looked at people who
have things or whether it be,
if you have a nice home or a nice car,
whatever,
it is a nice family.
I always inspire to do that.
I don't begrudge anybody that has a lot.
I've always looked at it as I want to
be where that person is approach to,
you know,
being a bitter,
bitter.
Yeah.
That's very healthy.
I mean,
man,
it just,
just having,
having a treadmill,
whatever,
whatever it is,
the treadmill you showed me on,
man,
that's,
that's not,
I want to get something like that.
I mean,
I just,
I just always looked.
I want to be around people who,
you know,
are inspiring.
Yeah,
me too.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's one of the best
things about this podcast.
So I get a chance to talk to really
interesting people and uncle all walks of
life and you know,
it's weird,
all the worlds mixed together,
but all those interesting
inspirational people,
it's definitely made me
more aware and smarter 100%.
It made me more aware of things,
made me reconsider my positions on things,
made me,
uh,
like,
like we're talking about David Goggins.
I mean,
I just think about that kind.
I want to work out harder.
I do,
there's a part in the book,
I think he went to support his either
mother's sister and a race and then in Las
Vegas.
And then I think he just took
off and left like he was,
he was there for them.
Isn't the,
isn't there a part where he just like,
he was in dress shoes and he,
he's just started running.
That's,
that's him.
Then I was like,
he's a fucking savage.
He's a legit,
and what's great about him,
one of my favorite parts about David
Goggins is that he's real honest about who
used to be that he was like 300 pounds
of fat and lazy and he's drinking
milkshakes and he just was depressed
and couldn't get his shit together.
And then he hardened himself up through
some strange force of will and became
that guy,
decided he wanted to
become that guy who was,
as he puts it uncommon
amongst uncommon men.
You know,
that he just decided I'm
going to be the motherfucker,
have motherfuckers and then he's so
much light that when people around them,
they're like,
oh Jesus.
Because he's so fucking intense.
Like you got to ramp it up to like,
I'm not ready for Coggins right now.
I was going to do 20 sit ups and 20 Chin
ups and 20 pushups and I was going to
go home.
This motherfucker wants
to run till we die,
you know?
But that's those people.
I don't know how many people Goggins is
inspired that listen to this podcast and
all of a sudden they're out there hustling
and they're out there doing things on
a level that they never did before.
And they're putting in that work
and exerting themselves in that way,
you know?
And he rubbed some people the
wrong way because of that,
because he's so aggressive and intense.
Some people are just reluctant to,
to be inspired by a guy like that.
They're almost like,
it's too much.
Well,
he's been there.
He's been,
he's been there,
he's been in the,
in the basement of life.
You know what I mean?
300 pounds didn't really come from a,
you know,
the father was a,
and he,
and he willed himself out of it.
So I mean,
if he could do it,
you know,
why can't I run another mile and a half?
And there's a video that I listened and
two from,
uh,
my friend Jocko,
Jocko Willink,
who's a navy seal commander and he's
got this video and it's just says it's
just,
it's,
I think it's called good because
it's how he looks at everything.
Oh,
you hurt your ankle.
Good more time to work on other things.
You know,
you didn't get to promotion.
Good,
good.
Everything's good.
Everything good.
That's like how he looks at things.
And I've been like running hills halfway,
fucking dead,
exhausted camp reads like,
oh your lungs were on fire.
You've got an opportunity
to get better shape.
I good.
Keep pushing.
This is what it's all about.
Good.
This is an opportunity to,
to face the intensity of this moment.
You got to play that,
play that video,
play that video just to just a freak
Sebastian now cause this is something I
will,
I'll listen to this like where my guys
work for me every three or four months.
Call me up or pull me aside with John.
Major problem,
some issue that was going on and he'd
say possibly we got this and that and the
other thing.
And I looked at him and I'd say,
good.
And finally one day he was telling me
about some issue that he was having some
problem and he said,
I already know what you're going to say.
I said,
well,
what am I going to say?
You said you're going to say good.
Uh,
he said,
that's what you always say when
something is wrong in going bad.
You always just look at me and say good.
And I said,
well,
yeah,
when things are going bad,
there's going to be some good
that's going to come from it.
Didn't get the new high
speed gear we wanted.
Good.
Didn't get promoted.
What time you get back?
Oh,
mission got canceled.
Good.
We can focus on the older one.
Didn't get funded,
didn't get the job you wanted.
Got Injured.
Sprained my ankle,
got tapped out.
Good.
Got Beat.
Unexpected problems.
Good
opportunity to figure out a solution.
That's it.
When things are going bad,
don't get all bummed out.
Don't
Darbell.
Don't get frustrated.
If you can say the word good,
guess what you need.
You're still alive.
It meets,
you're still bleeding.
And if you're still breathing,
you still got some fight left in you.
Get up,
dust off,
reload,
recalibrate,
reengage.
Go out on the attack.
Come on.
Don't you want to just go run
through a fucking wall right now,
Joe?
Good.
I think of that all the time.
That's a legit thing that bounces
around in my head when I'm tired.
When something's wrong in my life.
I think,
good,
good.
Don't be a bitch.
Look at this the right way.
He's going to have,
the things are going to go wrong.
Yeah,
they always do.
If they don't,
you're not trying anything unusual,
you know,
doing anything difficult.
You're not stretching yourself out.
Yeah.
I like looking at videos
that and being introduced
to guys like that.
Man.
That's how I got introduced to Goggins.
Someone played a video of him.
Um,
the doctor,
Eric Thomas is a motivational speaker who,
uh,
love listening to,
I love listening to
people who get me mode of,
I need.
Yeah.
Jocko has got a great podcast to you guys.
A navy seal.
He's a motherfucker.
He's a,
he's a very interesting cat.
Extremely intelligent but
just as manly as they come,
you know,
and just fucking owns it.
And you,
you know,
you see that guy talk.
One of the reason why
that's so inspirational is
because that's really him.
You go to his Instagram every day.
There's a photograph of his watch at four
30 in the morning cause that's when he
gets up to train the trains by himself.
And then we'll take a photo of the puddle
that's on the ground after he's done.
And then he earns the sunrise.
So he gets up and he goes to the fucking
beach and he sees the sun come up after
he's done training.
He's a savage.
That's a real savage
guys.
I get up at four four 30 in
the morning and I'm like,
what happened at taking a nap?
Well he'll take a nap later,
but the point is he makes him sound like
it's nothing wrong with taking a nap.
Probably.
No,
but this is that occasion.
He'll get his whole fucking
Instagram is pictures of his watch.
He so fuck and I'm all,
but he's really doing it too.
He's a Brazilian jujitsu black belt,
like a very high level black belt.
He's tapped some worldclass competitors
and a fucking great guy too.
Cool.
Yeah,
I'll definitely,
she was a guest on Tim Ferriss,
his podcast.
That's how I heard about him.
Then I had them on mine and uh,
me and Tim both convinced
him to do his own podcast.
Now it's hugely popular.
It's got a great book out.
Uh,
what is it,
a extreme ownership.
Yeah,
he's,
he's fantastic.
He'll definitely look at them.
Yeah.
People like that are so important
because they give you this step.
Just that little push,
they change the frequency
of your brain and make you,
gets you fired up.
But you can even accomplish a lot of
things because of people like that.
You know,
there's,
there's extra gears to be had extra
horsepower to be put to things.
Totally
good,
good.
Yeah.
So now that you've done,
you know,
four sold out shows in
Madison Square Garden,
I mean this is the fucking pinnacle
of any standup comics career.
There's only a handful of comics
that have ever been able to do that.
This is like dice Louis,
c k there's a few others.
I mean,
this is a,
you're in a rare place.
Do you have other goals or are you just,
just working on maintaining and continuing
to put on good shows for your fans?
That's been the goal.
I,
I'm not a goal guy.
I don't,
I don't say,
Hey,
this is my goals this year.
Uh,
I never planned on doing
Madison Square Garden.
My only goal when I got into this
business was to do it for a living.
I want to do standup comedy for a living.
And now wherever it takes me,
it takes me,
it took me to the garden.
I'm not looking at my
vision board and going,
doing Nevada can next.
It's a believe in the secret.
Wherever this takes me,
it takes me.
Um,
I,
you know,
to do the Madison Square Garden was,
was fabulous.
It was a great experience.
Nothing,
nothing quite like the rush of going out
in front of 18,000 people in the round.
And,
and,
you know,
having your family witnessed it.
My mother,
when she walked into the arena,
started crying.
You know,
she was there when I was being her.
You gave birth to this little tiny baby
and this little tiny baby is got four
sold out shows at Madison Square Garden.
It hit her,
it hit her hard.
And uh,
you know,
she was you too.
To see it hit her.
Oh Man.
I was,
listen,
I'm an emotional guy.
So to see my,
I brought my little baby and Ilana on
stage for a photo at the end of it,
uh,
I brought my father on stage.
I brought my mother and my sister on stage
to kind of like share in that moment.
Uh,
so yeah,
when my mother walked in
and empty arena and saw it,
uh,
you know,
she had flashbacks to in 1998 when I did
xannies and we had to get friends and
family there to fill the audience.
And then now she walks
in and her son's doing,
uh,
for these,
you know,
it was,
it was a great,
I'm so glad my parents were alive to
see that it would have been a shame if,
if they weren't there because they'd
been on this journey from the beginning.
These are parents who,
when I told them in 1996 that I was going
to go out to Los Angeles to pursue a
standup career,
didn't look at me and go goatee
and not still looked at me and go,
hey,
you know what,
if you think you've got what it takes,
get the hell out there.
They'll put yourself a time limit.
No.
Some people say,
Eh,
if I don't do it in five years,
I'm going to quit or whatever.
So when I came out here,
it was all in,
you know,
if I said five years,
I wouldn't have been here.
I would've been back a in
Chicago working at Motorola,
who knows.
Uh,
so family's always been really,
really key to my success.
Uh,
having people were very
supportive and my wife,
who's a huge,
huge reason I am doing what I'm doing.
I mean,
you know,
to have a wife to deal with the life of
a comedian on the road away from home a
lot,
I mean,
you've got to have like a strong,
strong woman to be in your
corner to put up with that.
Also just to deal with the
Weirdo of fucking comics.
A weird person.
Yeah.
I mean,
just the,
just the mentality of a comedian is,
is,
is tough to be around.
Not Tough.
It's just,
you know,
we're always,
in our own heads sometime.
So yeah.
So to answer your question,
where do I go from here?
I don't know.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm enjoying doing some movies.
I just started dipping
my toe to some of these
movies at the green book,
which is out now,
and a nominated for some
awards for the Oscars.
Happy to be a part of that.
And then,
uh,
I like it.
I exercising a different muscle,
um,
when it comes to acting,
but not comedic acting.
I liked the dramas.
Uh,
I like,
uh,
I,
I'm a serious guy.
Uh,
generally speaking,
I'm not a goof ball.
I'm not the guy always the center of
attention and it's just not who I am.
So I like kind of being serious and,
and,
and acting in a drama kind
of place to kind of who I am.
It's kind of a serious guy.
Uh,
and I like it.
I,
I get my fix from doing
the stand up on stage.
I don't need to do it in a movie.
So I liked the challenge number one.
And number two,
um,
uh,
I just liked to do different,
different things a little
bit outside the box.
Um,
so I liked,
I liked doing it.
I mean,
did this gangster movie
coming out with Scorsese and,
oh shit.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
That it's called the work with Scorsese.
Yeah.
So it's called the I Shit Irishman.
What is it about?
It's about basically Jimmy Hoffa
and how they killed him to this guy.
I de Niro plays the Irishman.
Jimmy Hoffa is played by Pachino Pat.
She's in the movie,
so,
and I played crazy Joe Gallo.
Um,
and uh,
my first day on the set was
with a de Niro and Peshy.
So,
uh,
the fuck was that lie?
Uh,
yeah.
So,
um,
I was shitting.
I mean there's no,
who is that on the left?
Pachino get the fuck Outta here.
Wow.
That's incredible.
I mean,
maybe it's just that photograph,
but it barely looks like,
you know,
I know that the,
this is coming out on Netflix.
That's crazy.
How different he looks.
Wow.
That's a Netflix movie,
Huh?
Yeah.
Fucking Netflix,
Huh?
Yeah,
it's a,
it's like $145 million project and they,
uh,
it's coming out on October two.
What is it like to just being around
Scorsese on a movie set and realize you're
a fucking actor in a Scorsese movie?
That's got to be,
I mean that is about as high level as is,
but it's like either Francis Ford Coppola,
Scorsese,
there's like a few people that
if you're on a set with them,
you know,
Kubrick,
when he was alive like Holy Shit,
that was a holy shit moment for me.
I was,
listen,
I am by no stretch of the imagination,
a seasoned actor and then to get
thrown into this group of people,
uh,
and,
and working with them.
I mean I gotta tell Ya,
there was a sense of doubt.
Like,
you know,
sometimes they're like,
should I be here?
You know,
is,
is this,
is this happening?
And then you know,
to do the scene with the neuro and Peshy.
It was almost
like after the first scene,
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
I should be here.
It's all the anticipation,
a leading up to the moment
that is unfamiliar to you.
Then once you do it,
you feel like,
man,
I,
that was all in my head and I made
it sound like it was going to be,
cause I was just thinking
the negative too.
I always think,
oh,
I'm going to screw this up and this.
And that's the way,
that's what motivates me.
I never looked in the positive,
always come from a negative place.
But,
uh,
once,
once I did that first scene
with them and they were,
these guys were more than uh,
helpful,
uh,
working with them.
I mean,
Scorsese,
when he came out,
it was friendly.
Nice.
You know,
it was,
it was encouraging to be around
that kind of positive energy.
Did you have a hard time
sleeping the night before?
Oh yeah.
I didn't sleep,
I don't think for the first
week leading up to the scene.
Um,
because I knew it was going to be with
De Niro and Peshy when they did was they
took Gotham comedy club in New York
City and they made it the Copa Cabana,
which I thought was fitting because
Gotham comedy club is kind of where I did
all my standup in New York.
I didn't really do any other club,
but Gotham and then here,
Great Club,
[inaudible] brothers who
run it are fantastic guys.
And,
uh,
they,
they stayed transformed the Gotham
comedy club into the Copa Cabana.
And,
uh,
Don Rickles is played by Jim Norton.
Uh,
no shit,
I'm watching.
I'm watching him on stage with,
um,
it's just crazy.
And he's like,
yeah,
no,
it's perfect.
Rickles.
I'm just thinking about that.
He's perfect for that.
He really did a fantastic job.
Really,
really did a great smile.
Smiles.
Almost like Rickles ask.
Yeah,
they gave him a little bit.
Ah,
oh,
that's fantastic.
Cast and great.
Wow.
I mean,
come on.
Slow.
The fuck else would be better.
You got to get them fat
that they fattened him off.
Did he give him makeup to fatten up?
But they make him eat.
Uh,
they made them,
I think they made them bald
and they gave him a fat suit.
No Shit.
Wow.
So that's amazing.
I mean,
the Jim Norton's a guy known for what
the 20 years and now I'm sitting there
watching him as Don Rickles in a movie.
It was just blowing my mind,
just blowing my mind.
But this thing is going to be,
I can't wait to see it.
I didn't see any of the movie,
even when I was doing it.
I even look at what I was doing.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I'm really excited to see
what this thing looks like.
God Damn,
that's phenomenal.
What a milestone.
A movie with Deniro output Chino,
Joe Judge has,
she a fucking Scorsese
film Harvie cartels.
Holy Shit.
By Bobby kind of allies in it.
Harvey cartel.
A lot of people never
saw the bad lieutenant.
Did you ever see the middle of the 10?
I've never seen it.
Oh my God,
the Carby Kai tell has
been amazing and virtually
everything he's ever done.
But the bad lieutenant is one of those
movies that's so fucked up and so crazy.
And it was a about a bad cop,
like all fucking really bad co and uh,
like completely,
totally out of control.
But it is one of those
movies where after it's over,
you know the credits roll and you just
sitting there trying to catch your breath
just going,
Jesus Christ,
what the fuck did I just watch?
There's a AH,
without Jackie was it says 93 but they
remade it with Nicholas cage a couple of
years ago to get the fuck
out of here was not bad.
It's not the same.
No,
no.
I love Nicolas Cage,
but no,
you stick to driving that Eleanor
Mustang and gone in 60 seconds.
You can't be bad lieutenant
you son of a bitch.
Nothing.
You're not a great actor,
but look,
it's just,
there's certain guys that take
over a role and to do that again,
like here's one,
like say if they offered you taxi driver,
they say,
hey,
we're going to do taxi driver again.
You'd have to be like,
yeah,
good luck cast and somebody else
get the fuck away from me with that.
You can't be,
you can't be Dinero in taxi
driver unless you're deniro.
Like that movie Cape Fear.
Another one he nailed.
It's by,
by the way,
Kate fear was,
I think someone else was
that character before.
I think Robert Mitchum I think played
the same role that Deniro played,
but I didn't know that when I saw it,
when I saw it.
I just thought it's fucking denier.
I can 62 there it is.
Yeah,
but if they tried to do it today,
like get the fuck out of here.
No,
no,
no.
You can't.
Especially taxi drivers,
you can't recreate that
role with another actor.
No bad lieutenant.
Nobody's seen that.
Nicolas cage bad lieutenant.
Even Nicolas Cage
probably didn't watch it.
It might've been like a sequel.
I don't know if it was a remake
cause it's called port of call.
Like it's got an extension on the
end of the port of call New Orleans.
It's called bad lieutenant
port of call New Orleans.
Yeah,
I heard about that.
Yeah.
That's the Nicholas cage one.
Okay.
So they tried to piggy back
on her or some shit like that.
Yeah,
but whenever that Harvey
Keitel version is holy Shit,
but he's creating everything.
He was great and pulp fiction
and he's great and everything.
Yeah.
Nice.
A fantastic actor.
And they really,
I mean the people in this movie are,
what's it like hanging
out with those guys?
I listen,
Joe,
when I went in there,
I told myself,
I ain't talking to nobody,
I'm going to speak when spoken to,
there was a part when they were
kind of lighting Deniro and I,
and were standing face to face and he's
looking at me and I'm looking right at
him and um,
I wasn't gonna say nothing.
And then he comes in on my tiny,
tiny needs to be tight and a
little bit and he sensed my thigh.
He straightened out.
So yeah,
I had a wig.
They put me in a wig.
And what kind of wig would it look like?
Actually,
there's there,
there that if you,
if you type up Sebastian Maniscalco
Irishman that it,
it should pop up.
Like,
yeah,
there it is.
What is the difference?
I'm so confused.
Why did they give you a wig?
It,
Scott's side burns.
I mean,
if you,
if you see it in person,
you'll understand maybe why I have,
but uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's not that much of a departure from,
from my,
my real hair.
But,
uh,
did they give you the option to grow
inside burns and you like get the fuck out
of,
you know,
again,
I didn't say nothing.
They said,
you're going to wear a wig,
no problem.
Whatever you want me to do.
Scorsese was like,
um,
okay.
Um,
there's a part where I'm going to
go through a window and he's like,
okay,
when you go through the window,
and I'm like,
Oh,
I'm going to a window.
Because I knew there was
a stunt guy involved.
Right.
But he's telling me that I'm going to
go to the window and I wasn't going to
say,
I don't do windows.
You want me to go to window to a window?
I'm not gonna tell Martin Scorsese op,
sorry.
I,
uh,
need a stunt guy.
But then they said,
hey Marty,
there is a stunt guy here.
He goes,
oh,
okay.
So,
uh,
I was ready to go through the window.
I went through a window on news radio.
Nick Dipaolo threw me through a window.
Is that right?
Yeah,
it's,
it's easy.
They're made out of sugar glass.
You just go right through it.
It's weird.
It feels like nothing like
a tissue paper or something.
It's very strange.
I was like,
whatever,
whatever it,
whatever it takes.
Scorsese wants me to go through it.
I mean the guy went through the stunt
double one through and he cut his hand.
Oh,
did he really?
So I dunno what,
what it was.
Oh,
if I would've went through to win though,
Jo,
I would've been dead.
So he's such a cycle.
He might've made the guy
go through real glass,
you know,
he might've been like,
this is just not realistic enough.
This 500 extra dollars,
the sugar glass,
whatever it is,
it's not going to work.
But,
uh,
I guess you could probably cut yourself
on that sugar glass shit if you landed
wrong.
I mean,
if it was sticking up wrong,
you placed your hand funny.
Makes Sense.
That's what it could cut
yourself a little bit.
But yeah,
the,
those exciting,
it's been really exciting for
me to last three or four years,
um,
to,
to have these opportunities
to do these things.
And um,
yeah,
it's,
uh,
that's great.
Listen man,
it's been awesome to see
because I remember you first
starting out at the comedy
store.
I really do.
I remember you from the late nineties
just trying to get your shit together.
And we did a lot of shows together,
man.
You know,
and then you really came into your own
and that during the time that I was away
and uh,
I was hearing from some,
you know,
comics always talk,
I was hearing from so many
people how hard you were killing,
you know,
so many people were saying you were
doing great and you've always been like a
real easy guy,
real easy guy to hang out with,
real easy guy to talk to.
So to see you blow up like this
has been just fucking good.
Awesome.
Well I think I appreciate that Joe.
And we've known each other for a while
and you're right at the time that you
were away from the comedy store,
I think kind of,
you
know,
found my voice in the beginning there.
It was really tough for me to,
you know,
to,
find a war.
I mean,
I think I talked to,
talked about this the last
time I was on the cast,
I was trying to like different shirts
that come through to come would it's my
nipples hanging out and
like a leopard shirt.
I thought it was cool.
I,
yeah,
it was one of those things.
You as a young comedian,
you train all these different
things out who you are
it out in the lion's den too.
You know,
I mean you are in the fucking
belly of the beast trying out.
Stand up.
It's very hard to do.
Yeah.
But,
um,
no,
but I,
I appreciate you,
uh,
the support you've given me over
the years and having me on the,
I don't take this lightly,
you know,
I mean,
uh,
when you had this podcast and,
became so huge and still
is huge to have me on here,
you know,
I,
I appreciate it cause uh,
you know,
I don't take anything for granted.
Well I don't take you if we're
going to need the brother.
I really appreciate man.
You got it.
Thank you very much.
Yes.
Sebastian.
Masako Ladies and gentlemen,
that's it.
Goodbye.
See Ya.
Okay.
Hm.